we have
major breaking news tonight and i'm not
surprised that it's happening on a
friday because
this is when news is released in the
with the intention of
killing the story but the border crisis
the migrant crisis that biden is facing
has now become
uh it's a historical record the amount
of unaccompanied children that are
coming to the border
and the breaking news is that the white
house border coordinator has resigned
this is happening on a friday night
which means they don't want the news to
pick it up and if the news does pick it
up nobody's going to see it because
tomorrow saturday and then
sunday and then by monday the news cycle
is just totally different
well the crisis is so bad that not only
did the coordinator resign
but the white house apparently now is
proposing cash payments
to illegal immigrants in an effort to
make them stay where they are
how about how about this the white house
says we'll give you money instead of
spending the money on you here now i'll
tell you in my opinion that
it's not going to work people are going
to say thanks for the money now i can
use it to come to america because
america rocks
so this just shows you that we are
dealing with this with a special
level of ineptitude and chaos right now
in the biden administration
ever since he came in he has been his
rhetoric has been very soft and we've
we've heard this as a poll factor
the illegal immigrants have already told
or at least one has told abc and
maybe another on one of these other news
outlets i believe nbc
because of joe biden because of the
opportunities he's offered they're
coming to the united states
and now the white house can't handle it
so we're going to talk about all this we
have a great guest talk to us about uh
the economy
and the the lockdowns we have john
tammany who is a libertarian author and
do you want to introduce yourself yes uh
i'm vice president freedomworks author
of the new book when politicians
panicked the new coronavirus expert
opinion and a tragic lapse of reason
uh thrilled to be on tonight thanks so
much for having me yes
cool yes and i'm also ian crossland from
ian crossland.net
here in the house talk uh about the
federal reserve with john
[Laughter]
everybody knows i'm excited about this
yeah ian just kind of lit up when john
was talking about the federal reserve
in the corner there are chapters on the
fed in this book
two chapters didn't you mention you have
a book or did you not mind i did yes let
me mention the book
oh no the other one the other one yes
there's a book called who needs the fed
it's my second
i make this odd argument that in fact
the fed has been rushing toward
irrelevance since its creation
so uh i offend both equal opportunity
offender
with my commentary on the fed it was
funny because when you i was like oh you
have other books and you mentioned one
of my books is who needs the fed ian's
eyes like oh oh what's that
let's find an answer to that ron paul
ron paul yeah all right everybody
this is crazy news we'll get started
head over to timcast.com and become a
member
to get access to exclusive members only
segments we have this huge library of
content at this point from all of these
different guests
you can only see these episodes if you
are a member and becoming a member helps
support the show
because the purge is real look they've
been going after stephen crowder
if stephen crowder goes many other
channels are going to get erased because
i mean he's basically at this point he's
a big channel i mean if they're actually
going to go after him
it's only a matter of time before
everyone else gets hit so if you really
want to support the show go to
teamcast.com become a member but don't
forget
to like this video on youtube subscribe
to the channel if you're listening on
itunes or spotify leave us a good review
leave us five stars a good comment that
really helps
but ultimately just share the show with
your friends because that's
actually the best way you can help out
spread the word get some organic growth
and we'd greatly appreciate it
but let's just jump to this first big
story and we'll just kind of we'll see
what's going on
white house considering cash payments to
central americans
to stem migration i love that headline
because the headline makes no sense you
should actually you should actually just
say
white house considering considers giving
cash to illegal immigrants
which will do nothing and they'll come
anyway and then it'll cost even more
money that's a better headline here's
the new york post reports they say the
potential cash
cash transfer program would be targeted
at residents of guatemala honduras and
el salvador
which counts for the overwhelming
majority of migrants illegally crossing
the border
roberta jacobson the white house
southern border coordinator told the
outlet
we're looking at all of the productive
options to address both the economic
reasons
people may be migrating as well as the
protection and security reasons
jacobson told the outlet in an interview
in march nearly 170
000 migrants were picked up by u.s
border patrol agents at the southern
border
a 70 percent increase from february
all right you get the gist of the story
you ready for the big hammer drop
who who was it who said that they were
planning on doing this why
it was uh well let me just read it that
uh
this is roberta jacobson the white
house's southern border coordinator
telling the new york post we're looking
at all of the productive options to
address both the economic reasons
and she's gone oh white house border
coordinator roberta jacobson resigns
as biden struggles to contain the
historic surge
in in migrants it's amazing because
it looks like this story about her
resignation came before
the new york post was able to publish
the story where she said we're just
going to pay these people
look america's awesome everybody wants
to be here i get it
i would love everyone to find the
american dream you got to do it the
legal
the legal way the law is set up not
because we hate people
but it's because we want to make sure
people don't wander through the desert
and die we want to make sure human
traffickers
aren't trafficking children we want to
make sure that guy with that little girl
is actually related to that little girl
and you can't do when people just pour
across the border so this is this is one
of the most insane things i've ever
heard
i don't know what you guys think i think
most people just their jaws just dropped
when once like the us will give
money to these people to make them not
come they're going to come anyway
it sounds like they're considering
bribing foreign nationals
to not commit a crime with our own tax
money
it's insane to me the consideration is
absolutely insanity to me so
you're you're more the libertarian but i
think would you say
little l or big l small small l it's
look it's it's guilt money
that we know what this it's guilt money
first and foremost
uh my point of view is that the the best
immigrant wall of all is a lack of
economic growth
can we let's not forget that from 2009
to 2014
more people left the united states and
crossed back over the southern border
than came in
as long as the u.s is awesome people are
going to
come here to me that is a market
phenomenon
that they're trying to solve with
central planning is it any surprise when
you solve something with central
planning that you have a crisis
what i would give if both sides
acknowledge
that there's a need for workers and so
let's
let's legalize work in some way it's
never going to happen because both sides
want to politicize this and they will
continue to do this this will never be
solved
it's like the people who say let's have
a flat or sales tax
yeah good luck it's never going to
happen it's not in the in the incentive
of congress to simplify
the tax code they will never solve this
with free markets
but do i guess one of the challenges is
different sectors require workers you
know not every single sector can have
the same kind of labor done
so a lot of the people who'd be coming
from central america they're not going
to be
computer programmers or you know solar
panel engineers
they're probably going to be low-skilled
workers or laborers is that a fair
assessment
it's a fair assessment in some way but
what if
we legalized work what if we said we're
not going to discriminate
based on on your coming from somewhere
else
to some degree people have to do low
value work once they're here because
that's the
the easiest way to not be discovered how
many cuban immigrants going back to the
1960s came here
they were educated but were bus boys
once they were in the united states
so once you legalize things you'd get a
greater disbursement of workers i think
you'd also get a lot more talented
workers to come here because we know
this well
if you're a foreign talent and come here
to school
you can go to school here but you can't
necessarily stay here i'll tell you this
that sounds like a way better solution
than just giving them money and hoping
they don't come
because i'm pretty sure if they give if
we give them money they're going to come
anyway
i i don't think giving someone cash
there's no contract there what is that
yeah well the coyotes will see that
money and say okay here's the money that
will help you get across the border i
think it you can't
look north korea is a police state
but people still come in and out of
north korea
we think in a free country like this
that we can keep them out and it's
always
struck me as odd that people on my side
say well
we want limited government but we also
want strict border enforcement
sorry the two contradict you cannot have
a very strong border enforcement with
guns and also have limited government so
to me it's always been make a choice and
i would prefer
that we'll we have a market solution but
that is my
the idealist in me talking but i i don't
i don't think uh
i don't think you necessarily disagree
with many of the conservatives or many
even even
pro-borders and libertarians i think
everybody agrees if we could find places
for these people through a legal process
we could keep track we could make sure
people are are succeeding well that's
great
the problem is they're wandering through
the desert they're coming with coyotes
and smugglers
kids are dying and so it's basically
chaos
right i think it was donald trump who
said something the fact of you know have
everybody come everybody but they got to
do it legally
that's kind of the idea maybe it is but
if they had the same rules that when our
ancestors got here and they probably all
got here at different times
most of us couldn't be here today if the
rules that prevailed today prevailed
50 years ago 100 years ago 200 years ago
most of us wouldn't be here
and so sure i would love legal too but
when you make the legality of it so
limited
is it any surprise that you get the most
desperate people crossing
crossing through the desert and
everything if you had a legal
process again a market-driven process
when you don't have central planning
i think what you'd find is you'd have
people coming the normal way
because there'd be an incentive to come
the normal way and you could have
fewer guns at the border because if you
say we legalize the work process there's
demand for human capital here
the minute someone steps into the united
states they become exponentially
productive by virtue of being in this
country
if you legalize that they're not going
to sneak over at which point you can
have fewer government agents
targeting the very few who don't
announce themselves in the first place
but do you think uh many of these
workers
displace entry-level workers american
citizens who are trying to enter the
workforce
no so one of one of the things and good
point
well we'll i'll follow up but i want you
to go more in depth but i want to make
one one point because one of the things
we've actually heard a lot millennials
say that around 2008 when they're
getting out of school and they're
entering the workforce the economy
collapsed
all of a sudden now gen xers are
occupying these lower skilled jobs and
they can't find work
i experienced this to a certain degree i
was trying to get a job as a dishwasher
because i was desperate
and i come in and there's some you know
i'm in my uh late teens
i'm 20 or 21 years old and there's a guy
who's in his 30s in a suit with a
briefcase trying to be a dishwasher for
minimum wage
i couldn't get the job it was impossible
so i ended up playing guitar in a subway
now we're hearing from the you know gen
z where they're saying
you've got all the millennials now
finally starting to you know come into
these positions and take these jobs
and we entered this this broken system
in shambles with an
economic crisis in our youth and now an
economic crisis the pandemic
so you have a lot of young people who
have repeatedly seen some kind of
struggle in terms of getting work
now you have an argument for many people
of relaxing the borders allowing more
labor to come in to compete with people
who have already had
a hard go of it um it's a fair argument
but i don't think we can have it both
ways in this argument we can't say that
they're coming in and taking the jobs
that no one else wants to do
at the same time saying they're taking
jobs from college educated millennials
but i'm not saying that i'm saying i try
to be a dishwasher and i couldn't
because
the work was displaced i mean dishwasher
i wouldn't say it's a job no one wants
to do you know donald trump uh during
his presidency there was a raid on
several meat processing plants in
cambridge maybe mississippi and arkansas
maybe a couple states
and i think they deported about 700
people and those jobs immediately got
filled at a higher wage
to american citizens so there were
several people who were interviewed
there was you know
this one one dude said they asked him
why are you coming to this job fair and
he goes it pays better than mcdonald's
and so these people came into these jobs
and then that opens up jobs in fast food
for
16 year olds who are entering the job
market who need to work
um should we abolish computers should we
abolish
the mobile phone should we abolish wi-fi
should we abolish your website because i
guarantee everything that i just said
has displaced all sorts of people
now my answer to that would be that's
called progress
because the world before that was a much
more
brutal cruel world for people
um look we could abolish the the tractor
the car and the airplane right now and
we'd all have jobs
we would be desperately poor but we
would all have jobs and so
this notion that people somehow drive
away
jobs ignores that where are jobs the
scarcest right now or
are they are they just abundant and
flint because no one's going there or
are they more abundant in san jose
where there are lots of people going
well las vegas there's lots of work
and it's lots of people moving from
places where there's not
it's work people don't drive away work
what drives away work is a lack of
investment
and so what attracts investment talent
so where the talented people go there's
always going to be abundant jobs and so
i think it's a mistake to look at work
as a finite supply it's rarely that
i would add too i think one of the
biggest problems we have in this country
is
cultural a lot of the young people that
i i reference
because you know we hear from people
saying i wish i could work but i can't
you know the economy the
immigration well it's also true a lot of
these younger people are really entitled
and they're told by their parents you
should be an astronaut instead of a
plumber
plumber is an extremely important job i
got to say
astronauts are incredibly important in a
certain sense that
you know what elon musk is doing with
spacex is going to
advance human human human experience and
human text not technology in amazing
ways
but i'll tell you this a plumber is more
needed
we we you need a plumber day today yeah
day to day um
you need substantially more plumbers and
electricians and carpenters than you
need
astronauts but they're all they're
important it's just you know we got
young people who are told
why should i do a trade why should i do
why should i figure out how to build
something
they want to be a rock star they want to
be a youtuber well even like a
successful youtuber needs to understand
tech i mean you would not be successful
if you didn't understand cameras
microphones
you know programming those are all these
are trade trades being able to work
cameras that's a trade
like a technology trade you know in the
industry you'd be like
in the union you know as a as a tech
i think i think you bring up a good
point i've i've heard similar points
made
particularly from libertarians and i
think one of the big issues
that i would agree with we need people
to just work
you don't need to work for someone else
you can work you can literally wake up
in the morning and be like
i found a piece of dirt on the ground
and i'm going to shape it into a little
man and sell it to somebody i agree with
value sell the value that work
is important but i think the job economy
is
part of the ponzi scheme of the federal
reserve kind of their ethos is
i want everyone working i want everyone
to have a job
i want this guy to dig a hole and then i
want this guy to go fill the hole back
up and we'll say yeah we'll pay them
both with
our money so they'll keep borrowing our
money at interest so that they'll keep
paying these people to be busy
and then they'll keep owing us interest
and then as long as they're busy they're
not going to realize that we're
a parasite on the system that we're
sucking this this interest off the top
and we're headed towards automation
where we don't need to dig the holes
we're building machines to do that
so as the age of automation dawns the
job
economy is going to is going to fade
away and it's all no
but in a beautiful way let's be clear
that automation and robots
are the greatest friend to the worker
that the world has ever known
and nothing else comes close let's not
forget that when
when you were born 175 years ago in the
rich u.s
your choices were binary in life you'll
either be a farmer
or something else related to farming
what changed that tractor backhoe
fertilizer the biggest robotic job
destroyers in the history of the world
did they put us into breadlines no they
freed people to become
astronauts to create cars to create
computers become math teachers
robots are going to take all that's
awful out of work out of it
all the drudgery out of it and allow
specialization on a level that's going
to lift
people that for hundreds years we might
have thought stupid
who suddenly get to do something that
uniquely elevates their intelligence
work is endless it's the kind of work
that is not endless in a dynamic society
and that's true
and the the big problem we then face is
cultural stagnation
people who want to be youtubers or
bloggers for buzzfeed instead of people
who want to explore and develop the new
technology
so i i read i was reading about the um
you know ancient rome in greece the
mediterranean
and how the great philosophers came
about and how math started to emerge
and it was because humans all of a
sudden find themselves in this very
beautiful climate
it's always warm there's fruit there's
abundance and so
a lot of free time on their hands some
people laid about and were lazy and
gluttonous
and pretty bad and others found
something to occupy their time
i think when the problems we have is
that as a lot of people when they when
they enter
this position where they lose their job
they complain to the government about it
what are you going to do you have people
on the left where they'll say something
like the government should just give me
money
it's like well you're not doing anything
anyway sure i guess
but then you have on the right people
saying we should regulate the industries
maybe bring these companies back a lot
of what trump was doing
i actually would agree more with you
know creating incentives for companies
to exist here
but outside of all of that i think the
big problem we have is absolutely
cultural stagnation
movies are just remakes reboots
adaptations
take an old comic make a new version of
it we need new things
we need people to be pioneers we need
people to say i'm going to go move to
the middle of nowhere in wyoming and
build a city
just there's so much work to be done
you've got to do it
i guess the the main issue though is
people want to be rich you're not going
to be rich
being a guy who starts a new city you
know you might be you might have purpose
maybe
and like yeah maybe like you were saying
a hundred years ago you
we were all poor when we were 200 years
ago we were all poor compared today
you're rich
like if you're sitting in your house and
you have the heater running and you have
running water that's clean and access to
the internet you're rich
you don't need billions and trillions to
be rich these days so
you just you know as long as the the
automation
enables the technology to be awesome
you're rich you did it
and it does look
ibm comes out with the first mainframe
computer in the 1960s intensely slow
filled a room larger than this if you
wanted to own it was going to cost you
well over a million dollars
nowadays i have a super computer that
fits in my pocket that i got for a few
hundred dollars that is
exponentially faster and more capable
right here our i can go on amazon
i've we've got alexa at home and i've
got access
to billions worth of music every single
day
for 4.99 a month we are billionaires in
so many ways today
because of the profit motive and what's
scary is to think in the future what
we're going
you you are producing a television show
with
three people here and then a guest like
me
that how many however many years ago how
much would it have cost to produce this
and you're doing this
from a house in rural maryland
it's staggering what's what's being
created
at microscopic levels of cost and so
when people are pessimistic and when
they tell you they can't get a job no no
no no
it's tim says no you're not happy with
the jobs available that you can get
it's kind of like there are years ago i
wrote an op-ed they uh
jennifer aniston is unmarried
by choice not because she couldn't get
married there are hundreds of millions
of men who would give anything to be
married to jennifer aniston
what's available she doesn't think is
worthy
what's available in the us for workers
is not living up to the standards
to what you elude entitled kids well so
this is uh
there is a challenge here though i often
talk about how here in the us we're all
fairly rich especially when you look at
other countries and
the you know per capita gdp yeah the
average american working at mcdonald's
substantially wealthier than the middle
class brazilian
i think their gdp a few years ago was
like 8 000
a year so even if you're working at
mcdonald's for only 40 hours a week
you're doing better the issue is we have
certain standards and costs of living
rent might be a certain rate so while
there are some people who are you know
you can point out we've got alexa we've
got all this great technology
you can get anything you want basically
shipped to your house i got japanese
soda
sent here japanese it's crazy it's a
little marble and you slam it and then
it's great and uh it comes here to the
middle of nowhere however
we have access to a lot of these things
but rent
is still really high so you can't be
you know you can't just go and work that
easily you know
i'll mention we need pioneers right go
and start a city but you need some level
of capital to do it
and if you lose your job because your
factory goes to mexico or china
you can't pay your rent or your mortgage
anymore and if you decide okay well then
i'll just flip burgers
you still can't just pay your mortgage
anymore it's you're not gonna be able to
afford rent
so there's work to be done but an
individual can't just snap their fingers
and decide to start working on something
and cover their costs
that that's fair enough but let's also
remember we descend from people who
crossed oceans to get here where there
were no roads no buses no airplanes no
cars
i don't i'm not terribly sympathetic to
people in modern times who say well the
factory left
well if it left get on the bus and go
somewhere else because
there is middletown ohio that's where
that's what
hillbilly elegy was written about well i
checked on the internet
the the uh it costs basically a gallon
of gasoline to get from middletown to
booming columbus ohio
in the united states wherever you are
if it's poor and depressed prosperity is
not very far away now i get your point
about rent
but compared to what other people were
up against in the past these are small
problems that can be solved and have
been solved forever
all of us have 917 numbers we're fairly
familiar with people who've got nothing
going to new york
because they've got dreams and they feel
view that as the place to test their
dreams that's what i did
yeah i went to l.a most expensive most
two most expensive cities in the world
basically
people figure it out i i this is that's
not a heartless statement i'm saying
to the rest of the world we are envied
wow you get to move within the freest
trade zone in the zone of opportunity in
the world if your skills aren't valued
in los
angeles you can go to phoenix you can go
to las vegas you know
where think about the rest of the world
if you went to the congo right now
and you just decided to drive across the
country you'd be killed before you got
to the other side
yep it's it's a good point about work
and being a pioneer
you mentioned not being able to pay rent
or a four-year mortgage is nothing
compared to what we used to do
so it's kind of like your jennifer
aniston argument is great
everyone right now is so accustomed to
modern wealth
and they couldn't imagine not having it
there was a period where if you were a
dad
you were literally like okay we're in
the middle of nowhere i'm going to build
a mud hut for my family or otherwise we
die
and you had to do it there was no
where's my house where's my plumbing no
it's quite literally dig a hole and take
a dump in it
that was the standard people lived in
now i don't want people to live by that
standard i want them to
to do well but perhaps if things are
falling apart and the system can't
support you
getting this job then we revert back to
maybe taking a step down maybe you don't
want to
maybe you're like no i was getting this
salary i demand that something well
maybe i'll take a lower salary and do
something else or
or we could i don't know cut back on the
rent
and the cost of rent and this subsidize
it with like basic income or something
this is just the first thing that came
to my mind but like i remember where
does that money come from the
the federal reserve so it's obvious
deficit spending yeah basically
hyperinflation and then yeah maybe
um or cryptocurrency or something well
how about we just know what we just plan
or we just cut down the cost of goods
not have a central plan
yeah you know again i keep going back to
the phone why is it that i have this
super computer that i was able to get
for next to nothing
i i don't know why but someone produced
it for me i think the most
look at what is expensive in our lives
and invariably there's a government
role a government hand we've got a
housing plan we've got a health care
plan
and they're really expensive and they're
expensive you look where there are not
central plans
and entrepreneurs keep coming up with
new ways to meet the needs of the people
and so i think the mistake is
let's stop burdening ourselves with well
what are you going to do
i don't know what i'm going to do but i
know that
where there's freedom people keep
producing for the needs of the people
with the least
what is certainly true is that what the
rich enjoy in a free society is
always and everywhere a preview of what
we'll all enjoy if markets are free
again we have super computers in our
pockets i guarantee within the next 10
years
private flight is going to be common for
typical middle class people
and by and within 20 years poor people
will be flying on private jets
bank on it maybe maybe but this green
new deal stuff this this great reset
stuff
they're trying to you know make rules
for thee but not for me if the
authoritarianism kicks in it'd be the
opposite
of course you're saying the free market
means we'll get private planes but
they're going the other direction
they would like to but they're not the
free market is way too fast for these
guys
and so i i prefer to be optimistic and i
think history
vindicates that that uh we're going out
we're going to outrun the planners
i think you might be right i hope so
you're out running the planners look at
this
you're about to start you're you're out
running them right now you're yeah
you're talking about a sitcom do you
realize how difficult it used to be
how expensive it used to be the barriers
to entry to making a tv show
and yet you were talking about it from
right here but the problem we face
is that there are very powerful
interests authoritarian interests that
want us removed from the internet and
they have influence
and they they try to do it every single
day always always
phil knight spent the first 18 years of
nike's existence thinking this will be
the last
tomorrow will be the last day of nike
think back to jeff bezos of amazon it's
easy to look at the
the multi the 100 billionaire 200
billionaire today but
think back to the amazon.org days do you
remember what a joke he was do you
remember how you were laughed at oh
amazon oh please they can't make a
profit they peddle books and they do it
so very unprofitably
there are always people in the present
trying to push down the future
i'm talking to three futurists right
here you're talking about things i've
never heard of
and that should make you confident did
you know that you can
commission a private plane for only a
couple hundred bucks
i didn't but it speaks to my argue
that's what i've been predicting for
quite
and who needs the fed i made the
argument that private flight will soon
enough become
so common good it's actually a really
obvious
it's actually really obvious that this
thing exists basically
people on private planes sitting around
costs them money
wasting time so what they do is they'll
be like six to 12 seats on a small plane
and you pay for one of those seats it's
literally how commercial flight works
but now you have a small private plane
with drinks it's only you and a few
other people it's much more comfortable
and it's easier and faster you go to the
airport through the private you know a
private smaller airport
you're flying on one of these corporate
private jets with typically the same
amount of people that would fly on a
corporate flight anyway
they're going to have six to you know
six 12 people anyway and it's only going
to cost you
you know several hundred dollars now it
might be some of these flights i looked
at depending on how far they go
they're much more than a commercial
flight because obviously
you want that private experience with no
other people bothering bothering you no
security checkpoints under that wasted
time
well you're paying a premium for a
reason so i've seen some flights that
are like double the cost of a commercial
flight but the cost has gone way down
for the average person to the point
where
you could actually afford it if you
wanted it to if you wanted to ah
i i always tell people this even if you
could afford it it doesn't mean you
should want to afford
it like if i fly i'm not going to waste
money you know
i not interested in spending ten
thousand dollars on a first class seat
that's insane to me but some people do
it
i guess if you're worth 50 million
dollars you you'd do it but
but i agree with you i think if this
keeps happening we're gonna get flight
of you know
we're gonna get the the uber of planes
where you're you're gonna say like your
your flight is at 3 pm
go to this small airport in this small
area and there's going to be a small
little private jet
no security no checkpoints no tsa
because they know you they've screened
you through the app you walk
right up walk right into the plane and
they're on the runway and they take off
and it'll be that easy they'll send a
helicopter to your house to pick you up
this is this do you know how much it
costs to uh
like charter a helicopter in new york
it's only a couple hundred bucks
depending so the it's it's getting the
point where you assume someone's super
rich because they're on a helicopter
it's like
actually i know the average person's not
spending a couple hundred bucks for a
helicopter
but you think this guy's rockefeller
with a helicopter it might be some
middle-class dude who works at buzzfeed
who's like
i need i need to make this quick trip on
this helicopter upstate
a couple hundred bucks and we're still
in the age of combustion i mean we're
kind of at the tail end of it but once
you know we enhance our battery power
yeah our energy source like
a fusion battery or something or a
nuclear battery or
even solar if you know obviously then
like they have solar airplanes the dude
circumnavigated the globe in the first
solar airplane i think it took them like
28 days or 18 days or something we got
to make our batteries better
yeah they're carbon twistronic uh you
know graphene are you familiar with the
hair gum material
it's mono-layered atomic carbon and they
figured out by stripping
scotch tape off of graphite they found
this layer of carbon that's like
amazingly electrically conductive and
they're doing all these experiments with
it they want a nobel prize
if you twist it 1.1 degrees two layers
of it creates a superconductor
i mean we're about to enter the age of
graphene it's going to make steel
obsolete
more or less it's lighter than steel but
stronger once production ramps up yeah
2029 i think is when we're gonna hit
start to hit peak graphene so this is
one of the problems i think i think it's
cultural i think it's absolutely
cultural
there's this poll that goes around the
study where they asked young people what
do you want to be when you grow up
and you believe it or not some of these
kids well first of all in in china you
know they said
astronauts what do you want to do when
you're as astronauts when they ask these
american kids and kids in the uk what do
you want to be
these poor kids they wanted the
stupidest job on the planet youtuber
did you believe someone being dumb
enough to make a career out of being on
youtube that's uh chris
the canadian colonel i'm only half
kidding who's the astronaut chris
um the canadian colonel yeah he was
making youtube videos he's a youtuber
and an astronaut no i'm kidding
youtube's a legit job but i'm not being
an influencer is more so what they said
don't you see how what progress that
represents though
it to an extent but beautiful what it
needs to be is
influencer or youtuber comes second
right
so i'm i got on youtube because i
started as a journalist at
some of these companies i was doing
technology stuff i was building drones
then i started live streaming then i
started working for vice then fusion
from journalism i'm like this is an
excellent medium to bring
political commentary news and and
reporting
for you mention the astronaut he's an
astronaut first he's an influencer
second
so these kids shouldn't want to be
famous for the sake of being famous they
should strive to be
something that develops culture and
builds on culture
but a lot of them just want to be famous
yeah i noticed this firsthand i was a
youtuber in 2006 seven and b
the reason it was exciting to watch is
because i was also an actor in los
angeles
and so the youtube was like a portal
into my main life
as soon as i stopped doing that and
didn't have a maine life and all i was
doing was
relying on the videos it became much
less interesting people stopped watching
and it's only when you're doing i fully
agree with what you're saying being a
internet youtube whatever this is all
supplement to what you're
really doing with your life and you can
allow people to see it and become a part
of inspire
people to do more as well so that's why
i'm really adamant about making cultural
stuff
so we we're going to be filming a vlog
with this bmx guy on sunday who people
mentioned the super chat hit me up and i
was like dude
yes we got a skate park here let's get
someone on a bmx to do some crazy cool
tricks
and we're gonna start making more and
more stuff to inspire people
to do other stuff the youtube stuff is
fantastic because then people can see
what you're doing be inspired by it
so to wrap this all back up into a nice
little package
we've got people who are worried about
losing their jobs
what we need is people who are going to
start their own job instead of
getting a job from somebody else too
many young people and going back to what
i mentioned about young people saying i
can't find work make work
what did i say i did i went and played
guitar in the subway i didn't sit there
and say the government should give me
money actually i did receive
unemployment when i got fired
don't get me wrong i like that idea but
uh i said well i can't get a job
i can sit around and starve to death or
i can take my small little fiberglass
it's a strata acoustic file
i don't know if they make them anymore
and i was like i'll go play some top 40s
that i like singing in the subway in
chicago
unfortunately you need a permit to do it
so i had to go to i had to go to the
what was the thompson center the daily
center
i go to the daily center fill out some
form and it gave me this laminate that
says like okay this person's allowed to
play music in a subway
and then i would play uh like oasis and
ccr
and i was just having to i was having
fun i would just put my my my gig bag
out
and i would just start playing the
guitar and singing and having fun with
it because i like playing guitar and
singing
and i would make i would make like 15
bucks an hour and then i i met someone
who was like
you know where you make the real money
wrigley field go play outside of wrigley
oh you'll make money great you know i
started making outside of wrigley when i
was playing guitar 60 bucks an hour 100
yeah bucks an hour you know why you wait
until the game is over
you start playing some top 40s and these
drunk guys come out
and they're like they're all singing
with each other and like rocking back
and forth and they're just
showering you with money all drunk and
happy and i'm like this is great
i found my own work you know now
ultimately
it wasn't enough to say like it's it's
not so easy to play eight hours a day
and
it's not necessarily marketable but for
a young guy in my 20s i didn't sit
around saying
someone should give me money or why
won't someone hire me i said i'm gonna
find a way to make money
and so part of my philosophy has always
been the simplest way to think about
economics and jobs and resources is
there's ian he's sitting across from me
he's holding a green piece of paper
i need to convince him to give me that
green piece of paper without violence
without threats
following basic laws and rules be
persuasive
provide something of value to ian so hey
man
i made this you know this little doll of
you would you like to buy it yeah and
says here i'll give you my green paper
oh that's all you're really doing you've
got a universal trade medium can you
convince someone to exchange that with
you for something you can offer
you make me think about the rent thing
because i when i was in la new york
in chicago i was so stressed all
every month every month i worked as a
waiter i made 700 bucks a week i was so
stressed every month to pay my
rent it was like the last week of every
month i was just like
like this gut this pain in my gut can i
afford my bills this month
and it was distracting it was taking up
my glucose it was wasting my time and my
energy
and eventually i decided i'm going to
live in my car
and i had no shower i would wash my
hands with rain water but
the stress was gone i had that for the
first time in my life i didn't worry
about can i survive this month
and also i was brainwashed like if i
can't pay my rent my life is
over but i would have lost access to my
my
house and my my shower that stress is
insane this is crazy
it's crazy to me that you know our our
great grandparents our great great
grandparents the struggles they went
through to have a family the the things
they did not have
no guarantees just hardship and today
it's it's harder than it was maybe today
it's harder than it was you know 20
15 or so years ago we had this great
economic boom under clinton
i was a little kid so i don't really
know a whole lot about how that went for
most people but i've heard about it
you know on tv and uh i guess then you
get the the
the 2008 crisis now you get the pandemic
crisis and the lockdowns
and people are all of a sudden having
their you know their chairs
pulled out from behind them and they're
hitting the ground it's a shock to a lot
of people
well getting back to ian
rent was this constant source of of
angst and i think that's true for a lot
of americans
but think about i'm not saying your
apartment in l.a was a palace
but my guess is relative to most parts
of history
it was a palace in terms of the
amenities and so one way to look at it
is yeah we're worried about
rent on spaces that in the past
people would say are you kidding me uh
you are living in a way
that rockefellers realistically could
not live
let's not forget that the first air
conditioner was created for a
minneapolis air
in the 1930s these were window units
massive
not even window units weren't even ready
these cost anywhere from 10 to 15
50 000 in the 1930s
now if you see a window unit it's in
poor parts of town
again what the rich enjoy is always an
everywhere a preview of what everyone
will enjoy
in freedom so not by 1930s
though right you're saying about today's
dollars oh no no 1930s dollars if you
wanted to but it was a ten thousand
dollar to fifty that's like the
equivalent of like millions
precisely that's why it was a
minneapolis air wow
who was buying the first air conditioner
and air to a fortune yeah yeah could you
imagine
so like you're this rich guy and you're
like check this out it's 69 degrees in
my penthouse wow
people be like wow so i don't gotta you
know i can rip off all my sweat rags
it'd be like if we walked in and they're
like all your
all it's all wireless power in here
there are no wires everyone can charge
everything
your phone is charging as soon as you
walk in the room amazing that that's
like
like man that's crazy i would pay a
couple million yeah
to be the first especially if you're a
youtuber you can show the world well you
know you know there's a statue
to the guy who invented air conditioning
in miami oh is that so carrier is the
most f is it
willis carrier that's yeah i'm i got to
be honest there should be because it
built the south
i i got to be honest it is it's it's
people told me this and i'm pretty sure
it's true
but i've heard when i when i heard that
because i lived in miami for a little
bit
i was like get out of here i don't
believe you and they're like the stat
there's a statue the guy who invented
air conditioning because
you could not live here without air
conditioning people don't get that
now it's remarkable
every building everywhere you go in
miami you can see
all of the condensation on the windows
because everyone's inside in the summer
or they're at the beach miami beach is
pretty awesome but they're inside for
the most part with the air conditioning
on blast
you know how they say think about what
that means because in india right now
1 10 and that's a high number of new
delhi is air conditioned
families are physically ill because it's
so
hot and they don't and you don't sleep
and so think about what it means that so
much of america is air-conditioned
well to to be fair london isn't very
air-conditioned either europe no
i don't know what their deal is we hate
going there don't get that hot
in america we have air conditioning
that's right i mean we are
we're a different people a lot of people
use kerosene as well in like african
countries and things to uh you
for light because they don't have
electric light well they got gravity
lights now
yes yes i bought one of those i love
those those are cool we should get one
we should
get in here okay you ever see a gravity
light no it's a a
high ratio gear system and you lift a
rock up on a
on a rope or string and then over time
the rock's weight
pulls the the gears which spins powering
the light oh cool
and then once it goes all the way to the
bottom you just ship right back up 60
bucks
yeah super cool but kerosene will kill
people a lot of death
from kerosene inhalation so we're what i
wonder is are we
have we caused a population boom that is
untenable like the white-tailed deer
they say
you need to hunt white-tailed deer
because they'll eat so much they'll grow
out of control and then they'll destroy
the ecosystem like
if we have air conditioning and
unlimited water and food are we just
gonna over produce and then become
eat ourselves to death is that like okay
thanos
is part of starvation part of keeping
the human population
level so what's the statistic if you
took the whole world's population right
now and jammed them all into texas
texas would look like san francisco if
you added oklahoma to it it would be the
equivalent of putting four people
per house with a yard in the house
we haven't come close to scratching the
surface
of the united states not not only that i
mean elon musk is trying to go to mars
yeah not that i think mara's life is
going to be i don't think people are
going to have cities on mars and maybe
maybe we will but there'll be biodomes
essentially you'll be enclosed and
and you know have to build inside
structures to maintain the atmospheres
and things like that
maybe but i think one thing people often
overlook is that technology
solves a lot of the problems of our day
so uh are you familiar with the great
poop crisis the the manure crisis of new
york city
no uh i could be wrong about this so you
guys can fact check me i want to make
sure but
i was reading about how the turn of the
century 1900
1800s 1900s in in new york they were
like the manure crisis will destroy new
york city because the horses are pooping
everywhere
and the population density is so large
they were like we predicted in 30 years
there will be piles of manure on every
street corner and
and then the car got invented and then
all of a sudden the horses were gone
kind of carbon emissions
now the carbon emissions are happening
this is what people say we need
to invent the next iteration of
transport that
solves for that problem well you got
tesla on the rise
it's not perfect because electricity
still generates
you know carbon in other areas but you
know hydrogen cells or maybe
some kind of solid state battery
technology because we can improve this
maybe
better uh maybe we we eventually
implement enough renewables in certain
areas
for charging certain vehicles we if we
we could offset
a lot of our carbon emissions with
renewables but
right now we don't have technology to
just end carbon you know fossil fuel
technology
one of the problems we have with the
left is they're saying get rid of all
fossil fuels out right right now
we can't do that but we can use nuclear
wind solar geothermal
tidal hydro dam stuff for certain
certain bits that we could offset and
then we still have fossil fuels for the
long-term stuff of the winter so we can
reuse carbon emissions too
almost immediately coming out of the
smoke stack you can recapture it and
then they could turn it into graphene
yeah you can condense it let's never
forget that oil
existed on this earth for obviously
millennia and no one knew that it had a
capability
and so to ian's point about that
graphene
we haven't scratched the surface of
discovering the different ways that the
world around us can power us can
can cure cancer all sorts of things and
so technology is going to fix this and
your
the idea that the gas-powered car is the
frontier of transportation
ignores history let's not forget in the
in the 19th century
whale oil was the fifth largest industry
in the united states
things so a dynamic economy like ours to
presume
that gasoline-powered cars are the
frontier no no no
we just have to overcome the
authoritarians these these these central
planners this command economists
these are the people saying we should
ban airplanes because it's bad for the
for the planet
could you imagine if we had all these
horses pooping everywhere and they're
like ban travel don't let people have
horses because we're worried about what
the horse manure looked like in 30 years
we're like let us invent
let humans invent it's fascinating to me
that you know that you know that that
old quote from the
head of the patent office where he's
like everything that can be invented has
been invented in like 1899 or something
you've heard that before
it's insane we didn't even discover the
electromagnetic spectrum at that point
now it's like man if this guy even
understood the the electromagnetic
spectrum
as well as petrochemicals men plastics
didn't exist
all of a sudden now they used to shotgun
shells used to be big thick brass
cartridges
now it's just plastic they still use
brass a little bit but uh it's it's
plastics replace a lot of things
the funny thing now is they're all
screaming oh but plastics are destroying
the planet
well now a couple things have happened
there's been developments in fungi and
bacteria that can
that can break down plastics and turn
into sugar and we've also seen natural
emergence
of bacteria that eats plastic why
because evolution
life finds away i think there's a lot of
pessimists we think the world is going
to blow up and just like we're all going
to die and we're doomed
and these people scare me because the
the look it's one thing
in my opinion talk about the political
conflict with these people that's what
i'm scared of
i'm not scared of the apocalypse because
i think humans are smart i think humans
invent
and every problem we've seen over the
past humans have done a really good job
of adapting to it and developing
technologies to avert certain things
however the big problem is the lunatic
ideologue authoritarians
who don't want that and instead say we
must have my command
central planning or effectively you know
fascism or communism
then they tell people what they can or
can't do and then what happens chernobyl
blows up i think at the elephant's foot
and people are dying and there's
radioactive carbon particles all up in
the air and everyone's freaking out
the command economists caused lots of
problems i heard a conspiracy theory
that the cia was involved with blowing
up chernobyl
i don't know i don't ever hear anything
about it they're not smart enough trust
me yeah
they're like there's no way that was an
accident i don't know um
what do you think is like the short term
and then medium to long term
what's your medium long term plan as
well as short term plan
for me yeah just to evolve the economy
and bring us to a sustainable
i think he's the not plan guy i i'm i'm
the not planned guy
and but for all the reasons that you all
are talking about we keep
discovering things and so i want to
limit
government and expand freedom simply
because
the resources we create in the economy
today are going to lead to such
discoveries
of new things you know politicians are
constrained by the known that's why i
think it's so
they say we're going to bring back jobs
bringing back jobs is the single
worst way to build grow an economy it
destroys it you bring back the past you
push away the investment you push away
the talent
no offense everyone out there pete the
most talented people don't want to work
in factories
so if you promise to bring back
factories you repel the talent
but there are a lot of people who want
to work in factories and have experience
working in it i mean
so one of the things i've often talked
about with a bunch of my little lefty
friends listen if there's a guy who
spent 30 years as a postmaster
you know he's he's in his maybe 60 years
old now he's had this job for a long
time
you're he's not going to go learn to
code he's not going to learn to build a
solar panel what's that
person supposed to do now i understand
there's there's a challenge a lot of the
left likes to bring up
you would you know you would destroy the
car industry to save big horse like
that's their joke
and i'm like well i don't want to stifle
progress but what do we do about those
who have lost jobs due to
proc due to technological advancement
through no fault of their own i don't
think it's fair to say you lose your
livelihood you're out
have a nice day you know what's that
person going to do
it's a great question but show me the
places in the u.s where jobs are
destroyed most rapidly i will also show
you the places where jobs are created
most rapidly
people talk about silicon valley as tech
and coder jobs
but the reality is that's where the job
creation is fastest for personal
trainers for chefs for baristas
everything for doctors lawyers and i'm
so i'm talking it's because those
services
yeah supplemental services where there's
talent
there's never a problem of job creation
but you show me the places where they're
trying to
freeze the present in place
i'll show you well it looks very
difficult times getting jobs let's never
forget that
i'll equip a pa used to be where
immigrants came to get jobs
it was the steel industry factories now
what did those parents say
tony dorsett's father mike ditka's
father all these famous
they said you get out of town there's
there's a book about this about this
guy frank morocco he got a scholarship
to north carolina state
and he comes back he got homesick at
north carolina state and he comes back
and his six brothers who all worked in
the mills and alequip were waiting from
the airport they said get
back on that gd plane and don't come
back
as in we live this this is awful you
have an opportunity to get out out of
aliquippa
closing steel mills did not destroy
aliquippa what destroyed it was that the
talent left and the talent left is the
parent said get
out of here well what about let's talk
about michigan right
the auto plants uh they move they move
overseas
they move to mexico or send some of
their work to uh to china
and then all of a sudden there's no cash
flow coming into these places
and so these supplemental jobs like
lawyers doctors chefs personal trainers
don't have income anymore and they're
forced to leave then you end up getting
brain drain in these areas if we
incentivized
or provided you know tax incentive or
resources to
factories to auto auto companies to
start factories there we could
revitalize this and help
americans in michigan i don't think so
and i think you know why
uh in the 1920s and 1930s guess where
the most factories were in the united
states the four cities
new york was number one imagine that
flint
and detroit were two and three los
angeles was four
if the departure of factories destroyed
cities
new york and los angeles would be
desperate monuments to the past
no what destroys cities is the departure
of human capital
and human capital goes to the future
it does not go to the past and so to
subsidize
keeping what the rest of the world wants
and
what the rest of the world will do
exponentially cheaper for you is the
path toward economic decline so
what then do you do when let's say uh
you know what factories did leave
michigan right yeah so then left
everywhere
what what do you think was the reason
people started leaving michigan
they didn't the talented people did not
want factory jobs they did not want the
past
and so when you drive away the talented
you drive away jobs across the board
but what drove away the talented what
were they doing were they there in the
first place i mean it was
unquestionably let's not forget that
michigan used to be silicon valley
detroit used to be silicon valley
and why was it it was because just about
every business
founded in detroit failed in silicon
valley today
just about every startup out there dies
nine out of ten it's a monument to
failure
but that's the source of its success
they don't they don't live in the past
there are no sacred cows
what fails is liquidated so in detroit
they started bailing out the past and in
doing that they created sclerosis
so what if what if they said new startup
companies
will get a tax break
i think it's a mistake be and i think
you know why that's a mistake look i'm
all for low taxes
new startups don't make any money to be
taxed in the first place it's a good
point
well so how do you get the smart people
back to a place like michigan
it's hard to say because let's let's
look at another obvious
american example seattle in the 1970s
was detroit
remember that it's not it's a true story
that there's a sign up with the last
person to leave seattle turn out the
lights
it was a dying city well bill gates
happened to grow up there so did paul
allen they were they started
micro dash soft in albuquerque new
mexico but they had an affinity for
seattle they came back
and in coming back they transformed the
city who knows
why but they chose it and then jeff
bezos these different people come out
there
talent very few the vital few revive
cities
government cannot do it and so to me the
only answer is to say
the last thing you'd want to do as a
buffalo new york is have a high tax rate
it's going to make it less likely
i'll tell you this new jersey drove us
out we were in we're in the philly area
just on the other side of the river
in new jersey and the the
authoritarianism and mismanagement
and high taxes it was very clear to me
you do not want to be here
and even now maryland is is pretty awful
as well
and so as we're looking to expand and
and we're looking at how we're going to
actually have a structure a corporate
structure that exists
beyond just this one show yeah i mean
these states are really good at driving
away
talent to be somewhat humble i suppose
we were looking at building a city a
couple years ago me and tim were like
yeah well let's do it we're sitting in
the cafe and you're like yeah it's by
this
well this small town in pennsylvania
will start it and i was visualizing like
me you and like six other people and the
firemen and like the sheriff
but now i'm starting to think if we
build it up around a university
like a late where we build graphene or
like uh a campus or something
anywhere near university well if we
build if we build a learning facility
that will give people a reason to go
there other than the cult
worship of like i hope i see tim poole
walking around town like
a real reason to build some some tech we
could build like even if it's like 5 000
people
like that's all cities started from
nothing it started with a few people
so so what we were looking at when we
were talking about this was that
what we do is internet based so we what
we do need is proximity to an airport so
that we could bring guests on the show
because if we're
four hours in the middle of the woods in
this you know small hovel
how we gonna get guests out there it's
not gonna be easy to do so that you know
puts a that kind of stifles things
but the general idea is if we can
produce content online that's inspiring
people we don't need to be in la new
york chicago or any of these big cities
we can literally be in the middle of
nowhere in the wild lands or whatever of
pennsylvania
and people are going to want to be there
and we're going to be able to connect
with people
might be a lot cheaper in terms of land
a little bit more expensive in terms of
importing resources
but then we can actually start growing
something and building something it
wasn't so much about creating a city it
was about
revitalizing a town that lost its
its economy first from one reason or
another so a lot of these towns i was
looking at
they used to be booming because of the
railroads
the railroads had to go through there
and stop and make various stops and
resupply
and this created peripheral enterprise
restaurants
imported goods fuel the train would stop
we need this that and this
we there you go now that we have
truckers freight
they don't stop anymore a lot of these
not a lot of these small towns are just
drying up disappearing so that was one
of the one of the ideas maybe we could
you know help bring back life to one of
these small towns
ultimately yeah we just decided to go to
the middle of nowhere for the most part
and uh close enough to dc to where
people could easily get here
what concerns me about the town thing is
the centralization of it because i'm
kind of with you guys i'm not really
into centralization i see that the
danger of it and the um
you know the the flaws in it the holes
in it it makes it you become vulnerable
when you centralize your plan
because people know where it is and they
can attack it if they want
um but also there's a value to community
and being around other humans
physically like you're here it's way
different than if you were on skype
no question so what do you think is the
balance of centralizing
city planning or cities in the future i
see like magnetic trains taking us from
small community to small community
why aren't we building maglev trains i
would love to do that why why
why is it that tucker carlson points out
and and bill maher this is amazing bill
maher took across and pointed out nearly
the exact same time within a few days of
each other
that china's got 40 000 kilometers of
high-speed rail we can't do it
why can't we do it is it possible we
could do it but
we're not going to waste the kind of
money again implicit in what the state
builds is that politicians have some
hotline of the future
i reject the notion of the opposite
precisely
and so who cares that china's got that
guess what go to china
you know what they worship is they
worship everything american
any city in china you go to there's
mcdonald's kfc
apple store nike store what we do in the
united states
is venerated there so i i i think
china's rise is amazing
but to pretend that what the state did
somehow diminishes what happens here
i think speaks to a lack of
understanding on the part of both tucker
carlson and
bill maher about what grows a society
and an economy the problem with china is
the authoritarian
communist party that has its tendrils
and everything there's a big difference
between like a regular person
really liking mcdonald's and american
enterprise and then the creepiness of
the
authoritarian state you know controlling
everything
no no question but even there people
worry about that well if the state is
that authoritarian if it's got its hand
so much in business that's a problem for
us because it means china's not going to
grow as much as we thought because the
more
china grows the more that we grow it's
the division of labor that's always
built up countries and so
i i think people mistake the threat of
china but i also think
it's certainly true that when you look
at look at china in a broad
sense um if they're going in the
direction that people say they are it's
not going to be a threat but
my understanding from it is is that the
chinese
the typical chinese person on the ground
doesn't experience the state a whole lot
but
sure why wouldn't china be a threat
though if they grow
because if they're growing economically
it means they're meeting our needs which
means that we get to specialize even
more which means we get to grow even
more
never is it true that a country growing
economically hurts others around them
by almost by definition they help us
expand because they do work that's not
in our
self-interest to do they make t-shirts
socks and shoes
and that frees us up to create the most
valuable companies in the world
so then i'll i'll give you a i'll i'll
reference a good old tim cast irl cliche
are you familiar with the city's trap no
it's a
it's this concept that whenever a rising
economic power
is about to displace the dominant
economic power war eras
and there's been for at least a decade
now fear that that's going to happen
within the us and china
particularly with the constant cyber
warfare that's been going on for some
time
then you've got the the strike strike
the chinese strike groups going through
the the straight
straight of taiwan i believe it's called
and their claim to the south china sea
the sinking of vietnam vietnamese boats
the expanding of the military into the
south china sea
into the atolls and recently we had uh
an elephant walk in guam and the the
i think um the us retreated
our our military forces and brought them
back to the u.s there was a fear that
china could have wiped out our entire
you know that entire force so
there's real concerns that with china
taking hong kong
right now they're doing beaching drills
which people assume is is
mostly about seizing taiwan that if the
u.s can't maintain that control
china's economic growth will eventually
displace the us and they're
they're on track for 2028 i believe
right now and then
war well if they go to war with us
it would destroy their economy now it
may be that they don't care about that
but and then if we say that their
economy will displace ours
no it would be potentially bigger in a
backwards number like gdp
terms but china's a desperately poor
country relative does they'll still be
exponentially
poorer than we are in 2020 their per
capita income right now is what 4 000 a
year
an aliquippa pa that poor depressed
american city it's over 20 000
so it's still a very poor country
but again if they grow richer they will
grow richer because the us
becomes quite a bit richer but isn't
isn't that per capita gdp just based on
the fact that the authoritarian
government
is authoritarian i mean they've got more
millionaires in china
for i mean for an obvious reason as well
they got substantially more people when
has the state ever been able to build an
economy like that we know
authoritarianism from the 20th century
we know what it looked like it smelled
intensely it was
lines for shoes that didn't fit and that
you didn't want
what did pj o'rourke always say that
bulgarian blue jeans ended the cold war
china is not authoritarian in the way
that it
what the communist world was in the 20th
century where the people were
desperately
hungry deprived miserable
to go to china is to go to a very modern
place again i'm not defending every
aspect of
about it but i think it's a mistake to
say that they're authoritarian in the
way that the former soviet union was or
that cuba is today or that north korea
is i mean
in what sense though they currently have
concentration camps
they would argue that we do too that
doesn't that this is not me bash the
i love the united states the chinese
always wonder well the us treated
indians in a certain way they treated
black people in a certain way
uh why is it that we're criticized for
for
for certain things that we do again i'm
not defending because they're doing them
now
guantanamo and because they have nuclear
weapons and because they're growing at a
rate that
if there is right now a country that
currently thinks it's okay to
engage in the formation of concentration
camps and ethnic genocide
and as another country the united states
the dominant superpower which doesn't
agree with that and that's
inherently better than the other why
would we let
a country that supports genocide and
concentration camps
take over the global economy and
challenge our authority
they can't a country can't take over a
global economy it's it's people within
it
the us is the biggest economy most
prosperous economy in the world but if
you went to
again burkittsville maryland would you
think that i mean
there are parts of the u.s that are very
rich there are parts of the u.s that are
desperately poor
same with china it's not a country thing
so
but if china the more china grows rich
by definition its wealth redounds to us
because if they're not
by virtue of getting rich that means
that they're improving our lives by
selling us things that we need which
allows us to specialize
or they're gaining influence over our
country's leaders
who then pass laws favorable to china
which suppress our rights
case in point when hong kong was being
essentially taken over by china
you couldn't buy a custom jersey from
the nba that said free hong kong they
banned it
people like mark cuban and steve kerr
came out in defense of chinese
authoritarianism why
because they were in on the take if
china grows powerful
and they gain access to all these
resources they start making more money
because they make our medicine because
they make most of our you know many of
our basic goods that we can't
manufacture anymore
then at a certain point you are going to
see our we have our politicians
we have joe biden flying his son on air
force two to china for a private equity
deal
and then they're going to be deferential
to chinese authoritarianism as opposed
to american constitutionalism and then
one day you'll wake up and find
that you have politicians saying things
like we should allow
the chinese way of life into our
universities which we have a thousand
talents program
you're gonna end up with people like
mark cuban a prominent tv personality
advocating on behalf of joe biden to get
elected and advocating against
the first amendment our own
constitutional rights what's what we
thought was going to happen was that
opening up china and expanding our you
know our trade deals
there was this idea among this
neoliberal uh group of
global politicians that trade lines will
end war i heard it from uh penn gillette
actually and
he's a i believe he's active in the cato
institute he said what ended
war between britain great the great
great britain and france or england and
france was
economics they realized they could all
become much better off and wealthier
but to a certain degree they have a very
different culture for a certain amount
of time but then they also share certain
values namely religious values and basic
moral framework
the united states does not share a moral
framework with chinese communism
so as china gains more power we thought
they would become more like us
in fact the opposite is true do you
think the state controls the economy in
china
i think that the communist party has
tendrils in all of their major
corporations
what are you worried about then based on
based on what you're saying they're not
a threat economically because
unless the chinese are genetically
superior in such a way that their
businesses
can somehow survive the state wanting to
control what they do and we know here
that the state is limited by the known
you guys are planning an all new way of
doing things economically
that politicians would be surprised
about because they've never even heard
of it
so unless the chinese are somehow unique
what you're describing
signals their eventual decline
economically i i don't think so they're
what what they're doing is they're
allowing capitalistic enterprise
while making sure that certain certain
things that would threaten their
structures
can't exist so for instance we see this
now in the us in many ways
if you say the wrong opinion or even the
wrong
name on these platforms you'll be
eliminated you you say complimentary
things you know we're talking about
doing a sitcom we're talking about
spanning and producing culture
at any moment any one of these the any
any part of the infrastructure the chain
links that allows us to exist could ban
us for an arbitrary reason
and we see it all the time people get
erased from the internet their opinions
are not allowed to exist
and there's an attempt by this dogmatic
cult to create a mono culture in this
country
very similar to what we see in china so
when china what the chinese communist
party did that was was
brilliant when they watch the collapse
of the soviet union
when they watch the failures of the
fascists they realize you know what
works
allow capitalistic systems to function
to a certain degree
and then make sure we have a place to
stop anything that would challenge our
ultimate authority and power
we want businesses to grow and flourish
but at a certain point we see something
that would upend our power
we shut it down so what happens in china
censorship
if you go online and say there was a you
know we we had this viral video where a
guy was
buckled to a chair and beaten by police
for saying he didn't like police
so sure they have mcdonald's they also
get their doors welded shut when they
get sick
and then they die they're treated like
like things part of a hive instead of
individuals
what's scary then is in the u.s as more
and more of our
our wealthy individuals our millionaires
our billionaires and
the lobbyists who are funded by them
started getting special favor from china
started having investments in china they
became deferential to china
you'll see these billionaires who would
say if i come out and say free hong kong
i might lose a million dollars this year
so i won't do it
in fact if i allow people to buy a nba
jersey that says free hong
kong china will get mad at me and will
lose our nba contract so i won't allow
that
now americans were actually barred from
saying free hong kong
that's that's a value that we hold dear
in in in terms of our history
with classical liberalism freedom of the
individual and the consent of the
governed china doesn't respect that
the more power they gain economically
over our industries and our politicians
the more those politicians are going to
keep deferring to china
and then come 2028 when their economy
displaces ours they're going to be
substantially
there's going to be a substantially
large amount of very wealthy individuals
flooding money all throughout the united
states to pass laws that suppress the
rights
of american citizens now the chinese
communist party
has their party branch and all of these
all of these companies in china
if you want to open a google office in
china the communist party gets a branch
well in the united states we're getting
something similar with the office of
diversity inclusivity and equity
this cult-like ideology of leftist
identitarianism
which functions in a much in a very very
similar way
and it seems in many ways deferential to
china so my fear is
if the united states continues down a
path of
culturelessness or cultural stagnation
and we keep deferring to
hey we all make money when china makes
our vitamin c and our antibiotics
eventually china is just going to have
all the money and they're going to be
able to pay people off
and it's been happening and it's working
and it's bad for us
case in point the numerous amount of of
university professors
who were arrested and charged with
taking money from china
without telling the us government so you
had professors who are getting grants
from the us government
and then also secretly taking money from
the chinese communist party essentially
or allegedly
to then give american research to china
so we pay for it the american taxpayer
the the american labor
and then china uses it to exploit us
they then gain more economic influence
they then give incentives to our
millionaires and our billionaires who
then turn around and tell
all of these local politicians all the
they pay for these commercials
and they run propaganda and politicians
that suppress our rights and take away
from us
if this keeps continuing eventually
china will will
will stage will actually uh invade
taiwan joe biden won't be able to do
anything about it the rest of the world
will say the us is unable to protect its
allies
and then china becomes the global
dominant power and then when you talk
about all this wonderful
american culture that spreads across the
globe it will start changing into
chinese communist culture
then in the united states which we're
already seeing calls for banning hate
speech
they're going to be people who end up in
prison and beaten for saying the wrong
thing
once we start losing our constitutional
rights and we are then how long until we
just clap and cheer and watch as china
takes over and we just do what they want
well because what you're saying once
again can't happen
if the states plan it you're saying the
chinese can control
the future they can control businesses
but implicit there is that they know
what the businesses of the future will
be
we see that as folly all the time in the
united states let's never forget that
back in 2005 blockbuster wanted to merge
with movie gallery the ftc said no
to dominant in home rental video so out
of nowhere comes netflix
and wipes them out if you go back to
2000
time warner wanted to merge with aol
government held that up for a year that
was going to be too powerful of an
industry you know there's no way if if
that's
that they're going to have full control
oh yeah within a few years that merger
aol was wiped from the masthead
back in the 1960s the view was that if
gm
isn't controlled isn't isn't constrained
by government a little bit more they're
going to own the whole car industry
by 2008 that same federal government was
bailing them out
so by definition when government tries
to
control business it is controlling the
past once the government discovers you
as worthy of plucking for money once it
discovers the billionaires worthy of
plucking
they've discovered the past remember i
submit to you microsoft in the late 90s
that was another allegedly impermeable
uh monopoly except for that it was
unaware of the power of the internet is
the unaware of the power of search is
they know where the power of of the
smartphone
is unaware of the power a list goes on
and on
so implicit here is that the chinese
once again
have a sense of what the future is they
don't and so if they are trying to
control industry
they will by definition limit industries
growth and they will not become the
economic power you think unless they
have a superpower
gene that the world has never seen
before but i didn't say that
i didn't say they know what's going to
succeed
you implied that they can control the
businesses
and they will limit them in certain ways
so as a way to limit their their their
ability to grow
in such a way that would threaten the
communist parties right existence
yes so based on that in the u.s what the
federal government would have done
is come after microsoft once again would
have come after blockbuster because you
know it was so powerful
would have come after come after time
warner and aol
government is always looking in the past
and so
every time if that's what the chinese
government's doing once again i've got
you've got nothing to worry about
because the businesses
that are going to be dominant in china
in the future
are not the ones today and that's the
same thing here if you have me back in
five years or 10 years
how much do you want to bet that
microsoft apple
amazon google and facebook aren't the
five most valuable companies in the
world
i'll put any amount of money on that
perhaps
but how do you explain than the fact
that already we are seeing
american industrialists support chinese
communism over american
constitutional liberalism or or
classical liberalism not liberal in the
political sense
well for one i think once again for the
typical chinese they don't experience
government authoritarianism
on a daily basis this is not to defend
but let can we at least to some degree
admit
that when we talk about the uh the
dissidents in china
and and we defend them and we get behind
them
it's kind of a rich man's concept it's a
paris los
angeles new york concept you think the
typical chinese knows about these
dissidents
they don't right so the the great
firewall and the support no no no but
it's it's not simple unable to fight
back i don't think so i think you'd find
the same thing here
go to aliquippa pa and see how many
people could have this conversation with
you i don't think it's
as much suppression because anyone who's
at all good with computers in china
can get beyond the firewall it's so easy
every time i've been to china you get a
vpn you can be on
you can get any information you want do
they suppress tiananmen square you
better believe it
but if you if you have passable
knowledge of computers in china you can
get all the information you want about
it
and so it's the same thing there the
typical chinese is just too busy trying
to make a living
to worry about this isn't me defending
it but i think this
notion that they're all repressed people
is belied by what exists over there this
if it were that repressive it couldn't
be that gleaming of
a country in many ways with buildings
going up and all sorts of economic
opportunity why do u.s businesses kowtow
look it's a huge market and why is it a
huge market
it is because the people there are
increasingly free to produce
in very entrepreneurial ways so long as
it doesn't
challenge the authority of the chinese
communist party and their goals but
again that
implies that the chinese communist party
knows what the future is
it doesn't i don't understand that
because they the only thing the ccp can
do
is take on what exists they built the
great the great firewall of china which
you said
some people know how to get past oh my
goodness but many people don't know how
to get past
and many people in the us aren't very
good at computers they don't have
near the knowledge of computers that you
the two of you do here yet they were
still able to
create dozens of websites and an entire
alternative media ecosystem that
challenges the establishment every day
and resulted in the election of donald
trump which really pissed off the
establishment
the chinese communist party is not going
to lose power because they'll lock
people up who say wrong
who say the wrong words very hard to do
because again what keeps happening
in china is by the time the sensors get
to it it's too late and it's already so
dispersed
never forget that you guys an
entrepreneur in houston once told me
after obama was elected in 2009 and a
lot of people on our side were kind of
downcast
i said are you where he said are you
kidding me i am way too smart for obama
i was way too smart for bush before him
capitalism and the profit motive and
technology what you guys are talking
about here
you're so ahead of the politicians and
to pretend that the chinese communist
politicians
somehow have a sense of the future no no
no but you
but you keep saying that and i'm not
implying that i think you're you're
assuming there's an implication i'm not
saying that okay so then let's
agree if if you if you make a website
called
you know uh i will descent you know
china
they will delete that in two seconds
because you are not fast enough
not fast enough what they keep finding
there is that by the time the sensors
get to it the information is already but
that's not the issue the issue is that
over several years in the united states
the ability of people to create
sub for example the donald
this was a massive community that
brought together trump supporters and
according to mit's technology review it
was
one of the most prolific uh uh
one of the biggest proliferators of
memes on the internet period
in fact many leftists were adopting the
same memes used by trump supporters
but just reappropriating them back
against you know in fa against the right
in favor of the left
these forms were eliminated after a
certain amount of time but for years
they were allowed to exist for years
certain personalities were allowed to
flourish and function on the internet
twitter called their website the free
speech wing of the free speech party
well one by one they started eliminating
many of these channels and they're still
doing it
the united states isn't the same as
communist china where they can just snap
their fingers and eliminate the idea at
a moment's notice
sure we all see the one meme but it's
not allowed to grow
it's not allowed to develop a community
is not allowed to form so people are
constantly struggling in china with a
game of whack-a-mole or the communist
party
is shutting down those who oppose their
power in the u.s
it seems only recently big tech silicon
valley these corporatists many of whom
are deferential to china and other
special interests have started doing the
same thing
twitter says we have a global policy so
right now on twitter the problem we face
as americans
is that an australian citizen can go on
twitter and say
anything they want about donald trump
say during the election
they can make up every lie in the book
they can scream he's an agent of russia
and twitter allowed that
but if you were an american citizen who
tried sharing a story about joe biden's
son
they would ban you block you or
eliminate that now for a long time
that's
this wasn't happening and it goes
against many of the values we hold here
as americans free speech free inquiry
china is the opposite they've always
been suppressing this information
and they haven't been able to is my
point they absolutely have much more
different no they haven't once
anyone with passable computer skills can
get whatever they want
information on what the government did
with tiananmen square and risk going to
jail
it's it's not a risk you can't you can't
censor everyone
and to your point about twitter look
there's no doubt but implicit there
is that twitter is the frontier of this
i guarantee you
within a year or two twitter is going to
be yesterday that's why i wasn't very
worried when parlor was [ __ ] when amazon
and
the others went and went after parlor
yes it bothered me
but i guarantee you what vanquishes
twitter
is a company you've never heard of yeah
immutable databases like blockchain and
ipfs like
like pocket net things with like where
data can't be deleted
you might be able to try and prevent
access to the data but the data remains
a netflix concept again remember netflix
for years tried to get blockbuster to
buy it and block this oh please
netflix really and then they wiped them
out
we're all focused on parlor right now
and oh it's just so unfair what big tech
is doing
guaranteed it's somewhat it's a company
you've never heard of that's going to
wipe out
twitter and some of these and believe me
in our lifetime how much do you want to
bet let's keep in touch
amazon's going to be wiped out by
someone younger the only constant in a
free society
and that's why we never have to worry
about china because they're not as free
is that the past is constantly being
replaced by the future and i don't see
that changing right now
big tech is a moving target and how we
know that is the only businesses that
don't think they're too powerful
that know their power ephemeral are big
tech why would they be spending tens of
billions of dollars a year on new
businesses and new technologies if they
thought that they
they had a dominant position forever
they're doing it because they know
they've seen how what were the big
internet companies when the 20th century
began 21st century begin
yahoo aol ebay have you heard about that
much lately
guaranteed within 10 years we're not
going to be talking about these very
much
because in the year 2000 mark zuckerberg
was in high school
and i'll bet you any amount of money
within 10 years some kids in high school
today younger people are going to
eclipse these guys
i'm not worried about big so how did the
soviet union start
how did it start it was a revolution of
workers uh they basically
wanted to kill the royal family there
was an ideology spreading of communism
and marxism and
i'm not gonna pretend to know enough
about the history to give you a history
lesson or anybody watching
the point i'm simply trying to make is
that at some point the country had a
dramatic revolution and changed
how did the how did what what happened
with the history of china i mean how
many people died in were killed in china
100 million
how many how many people communism 70 to
100 i don't know
it was a high note the communism has a
body but they weren't always communist
countries
no no no they weren't uh no i would
point out something
it's rarely the case that this wasn't it
wasn't a workers revolution in in russia
and it wasn't a war it's usually
it's upper middle class that foments
these it's no it's never workers
absolutely and right now what we're
seeing with the cultists is they tend to
be
these you know suburban white
progressives and a lot
not a lot of people like to hear that i
guess but it's it's mostly true it's
mostly white people who are critical
race theorists
so how do we maintain the freedom for an
industry to exist
when cult ideologies are taking over
much like we saw
long time ago in other countries i've
got an optimistic assessment for that
we're all free thinkers here ultimately
while our ideology i think i speak for
the three of us tell me if i'm wrong
we love freedom oh yeah if we were
running the united states
i guarantee you woke ideol walt cultists
would be everywhere
there'd be 30 aocs if i run in the
united states 30 bernie's and why is
that
because i think free people create a lot
of wealth and they create the very
wealth that people like bernie and aoc
can demagogue against
bernie and aoc and elizabeth warren are
a creation of the wealth they claim to
disdain
so in my world there'd be a lot more of
them i'm not surprised that there are a
lot of
woke cultists in the united states
massive
wealth creation and that is born of
freedom
cr allows for an endless stupidity it's
in the poor countries where people can't
be
revoltingly stupid so to some degree
i tend to look at some of this and i say
oh yeah it's boy we must be a really
rich country because look at some of the
stuff kids are able to do out of college
was was was china particularly rich when
they had their you know communist
takeover
yeah if you look at shanghai in the
1920s and 30s is a very advanced
city economically with some of the most
talented entrepreneurs in the world
and and to be clear a very uh global
entrepreneurial base americans a huge
jewish population
and then they became communists uh yes
very upper middle class uh chinese a few
of them took over
and it was destroyed the chinese have a
very
weird view of the world they tend to
look at things a lot more long-term and
so i think they viewed this and this was
a tragedy this isn't defending it for
a second but look it happens and so
we've got to be vigilant at all times
i'm not saying sit lay down our arms
but i'm not surprised in a country as
rich as the united states
there aren't shockingly dim people out
we don't make our own medicine
so what so what if china one day says no
medicine for you
are they gonna stop selling it they
could absolutely just decide to stop
selling and cut us off
so they'll sell it to no one they'll
sell it to no one they'll keep it for
themselves when the pandemic started
well
turned their ships around and took all
the ppe back well so what happened
do you remember 1973 the uh there was an
arab
oil embargo in the united states did we
stop consuming arab oil
i wasn't alive well it doesn't mean you
can read the history
of course not we still bought every bit
as much arab oil as we did before we
just bought it from those they sold to
now it's possible the chinese would go
to the expense of creating all this
medicine that saves lives
and sit on it keep it for themselves to
save their lives in a war
you think it wouldn't be smuggled out of
the country you think that if that were
the only medicine available it wouldn't
find its way to the us we've had a drug
war against
drug drug use in the u.s for decades
how's that work
how did that we still had a black market
would displace the entire pharmaceutical
industry and delivery
no if the only medications were in china
and they were sitting on them as and you
can't sell them
guaranteed that would be smuggled out
not in the quantities americans would
need it in a war in in which case very
quickly
just as we've been able to mobilize for
wars before you'd very see
very quickly see americans come up with
the answers to that which
that which which we don't have and so
i'm not worried about that the reality
is that the u.s could be at war with
every oil producing nation on earth and
be embargoed by every single other one
and we would still consume all of the
oil that they produce as though it
bubbled up in west texas
let's never forget that england in the
19th century
was at war at one time with every
european country
and embargoed by all of them yet they
were still importing all that they
produced
think back to world war one the us
imposes a trade embargo on germany and
guess what happened out of nowhere
suddenly all these us exports are going
to scandinavian countries
we were still trading with the germans
they were just routing them through
scandinavian countries
when the arabs their embargo on us in
1973 was entirely symbolic we still
consumed arab oil
think about it no not one not one cent
more it cost more because we devalued
the dollar which tim would tim would
know about
we left we left the stability oh yeah
i'm sorry but maybe he's right yeah
and and so you look at modern times
we've got embark trade embargoes on
iran cuba's got brand new cars for years
haven't they
well there are iphones all over iran
even though we've got a trade embargo
guess what's the main currency in iran
the dollar what's the main currency in
in north korea the dollar in venezuela
it's the dollar
unless you can shut unless the u.s
literally walls off itself in which
the walls would still be porous what we
produce is everywhere in the world we
could still embargo the rest of the
world we'd still be there the chinese
can't keep anything of value from yeah
but but there's a big difference between
free flow of goods and heavily
restricted smuggled goods
uh there's north korea is not
particularly advanced
you know i mean they've got they got a
city but if you look at
the nighttime satellite picture of north
korea versus south korea there's a very
big difference i think they're
underground i think they build an
underground kingdom
look countries can keep their people
down there's no question the point is
if the chinese tried to decide to commit
economic suicide by not allowing their
goods to escape the united states
escape the country which would be
economic suicide for them
why would it be because if you're why
would
why would you produce and not sell to
the biggest market on earth
why would you declare one another
country it's a very good question but to
be clear
usually wars with other countries are
what result
after trade has broken down them it's
much less likely
for countries to go toward it it's kind
of a hackneyed statistic at this point
but as of today i believe it's still
true a country with mcdonald's in it has
never invaded another country with
mcdonald's i've heard that that's really
interesting yes
yeah you know when you've got a rooting
interest in another country it's kind of
like
with the chinese uh invade the u.s it's
certainly possible but it'd be the
equivalent of gucci invading beverly
hills dude if that's a real
statistic that a country with mcdonald's
never invaded another country that's
really really promising yeah it's it's
uh it's from
one of the i'm not a big fan of this but
it's from a thomas friedman book
um i i think wait sorry
well i don't know if i want to use
snopes let's see what they say
have two mcdonald's-containing countries
ever been at war with each other
whether an economic theory involving
mcdonald's franchises and war literally
holds true largely depends on one's
definition of war
they say countries that both have
mcdonald's never have never been
involved in a war now snopes i'm not a
fan of
so when they say something's false i
don't necessarily believe it when they
say something's true and it's obviously
true i'll use it on purpose but they go
on to mention this
they say friedman's idea was somewhat
tongue-in-cheek and not necessarily
meant to be taken literally and
absolutely
it does not seem to have held true in
all cases they say uh let's see
communism suffered its first big mac
attack today is mcdonald's open up a
restaurant in yugoslavia and police were
called in to keep customers who lined up
tensions between different ethnic groups
so a series of bloody conflicts
in the 1990s resulted in piecemeal
dissolution of yugoslavia led to the
kosovo war
which was waged between february 98 and
june 1999
and pitted the forces of the federal
republic of yugoslavia uh
blah blah blah with the albanian army on
the ground it was the federal republic
of yugoslavia who's capital in belgrade
i'm not going to read the whole thing i
guess the general ideas they're saying
depends your definition of war what they
say in 1989
the u.s invasion of panama 1999 the
cargill war india and pakistan over
kashmir the 2008 georgian war
and the 2014 invasion of ukraine so it's
very limited
it's yeah it's it's it's it's fairly
powerful in the sense what's the
bastiot quote when goods don't cross
borders armies will
i mean countries are trading with each
other is much less likely
limited in the capacity of like world
war ii i guess
yeah there's only been like five or six
instances of it and it hasn't been
global conflict
when it happens i mean that's very
common sense
i would never want to invade a trade
partner yeah i can't say never but i
don't want to kill your best customers
it's just it's just only logical not to
kill your best customers and so i
i do believe the greatest cheapest
foreign policy the world ever conceived
of was trade
obviously because when we're dividing up
work and working for one another uh
war becomes very expensive what john f
kennedy's
father always said to him uh because he
was a global trader said son
war is really bad for business stay out
of the wars
unless you're halliburton unless you're
an arms manufacturer so we've got to
keep our eyes
interesting that you say that but if you
look at the companies the defense
contractors in the 1960s it's common to
say that
they wanted vietnam their share prices
actually fell in the 1960s it wasn't
war is a bad business and it's bad
business for everyone
all right well how about we take some uh
we move on to super chats and i will
absolutely say right now
i don't know what youtube has been doing
but uh the other day we had a bunch of
likes get erased
same thing happened today weird now to
be fair we do have some dislikes today
but it's absolutely like i i'm checking
this as i'm watching it happen so if you
like the show give us a like because
youtube seems to be erasing likes for
some reason no joke or the met or their
counter is wrong maybe possible
and her future is unknown if you have
not already
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel we're going to be we're going to
break a million subs next week it's
going to be great we got the new website
launching
soon at some point uh we think the
official launch will be monday but you
know we'll see we've got to make sure we
we cross all the t's down the ice
so uh smash the like button go to
timcast.com become a member we have a
huge
library of exclusive members only
content full podcast episodes
some of it's not even it's not news you
know the other day we're talking about
crazy stories with jim hansen you know
he's in he's in uh philippines eating
these rotten eggs they eat there's crazy
stories
and then a guy pulls out a gun and it's
just fun fun conversation so check that
out
now we're gonna read y'all super chats
all right so
youtube blocks the name of this first
super chat so sorry i can't read your
name but they say here's ten dollars to
make a tim cast irl fighting game
tim's super would be him throwing some
seeds and the chicken swarming the bad
guy
ian's super he drinks graphene and
becomes invincible for five seconds
i'm sorry i i've got i've gotta stop you
there um
i would love to make a fighting game we
will look into this and i think it would
be way more fun to make a culture war
fighting game
so a long time ago someone made a
culture war
fighting game image a meme where it was
super smash
brothers and it was the character
selection screen from smash brothers
with all of these different culture war
personalities and it was blue on the
left and faded slowly to red
representing left right and center and
then they had all of these different
people like steven crowder and alex
jones and tim poole
and you know sargon and and then other
you know leftist personalities david
pakman kyle klinsky i thought it was
hilarious
i think it would absolutely be a be
hilarious to make a
fighting game based on just political
persons you know would be awesome as if
it was a
two two-dimensional or three-dimensional
fighting game but you could at any time
zoom into your character and fight first
person
i don't know zoom back out we need to
develop the genre so
i like i like two-dimensional fighting
games but anyway i was going to say is
ian's superpower
would that he would have some kind of
like nano graphene tech
and he would pull the graphene out and
it would take different shapes
so ian would have like one special move
it's like down forward punch and then a
claw formed with graphene
and then it can also fire a wire of
graphene and electrocute you
back back b would be like a graphene
shield would like throw up in front of
me for a second yep i'm down
graphing i want chickens i don't think
my superpower would be would be chickens
or anything like that
it gets chickens yes okay chickens
chicken master karl roy says the debate
between ian and tim was great yesterday
i like ian even if i disagree with his
opinion on that one we talked about the
debate between objectivism and
subjectivism well no it's objective and
subjective evil right
there's a lot of evil or objective and
so can be i'm sorry to interrupt
yourself i was going to say a lot of
philosophers say there's no objective
evil
that good and evil are subjective
concepts and i was arguing for
so that that objective evil does exist
and we had a conversation with a debate
very it's a lifelong conversation
all right let's see keith mccracken says
hey tim i'm really bummed
out that you didn't discuss my comment
further but a lot of problems in the u.s
is undiagnosed mental health poor diet
and the lack of researching both ends of
the topic knowledge is
ultimate power you're the best ian well
there you go
i'm the best ian that's right the best i
can be thank you dude
okan cable says feel free to disavow but
instead of cash payments why not send
lead payments jeez no no no no no
no no no that's not a good monetary
policy
don't like that dr remulac says what in
the actual crap is this i'm tired of
this bs finish the wall and bring back
potus 45
please he was not perfect but he had our
best interest in mind and heart
well the good news is i guess just joe
biden wants to build the wall
so there's talk yeah yeah right
andrew platt says you either get banned
a tim pool or you stay on the platform
long enough to see yourself become the
alex jones
well maybe as one would put it i would
say those
you either get banned a tim pool or you
stay in the platform long enough to
become a leftist
there have been a bunch of youtube
personalities who all of a sudden just
their opinions just changed around the
time people are getting banned how
interesting is that
so what a coincidence
chris lieber says big shout out to ian
you're my favorite astral projection
fellow ohioan here east side of
cleveland i have seen crystal elves on
dmt and would love to hear you talk more
about the subject to start your own
podcast much love
oh thank you so you met the crystal
elves i have not yet i've not blasted
through on dmt i just puffed it the
first time i took
it and uh i was in a room my my this guy
was growing algae and these green tanks
behind him and i could see gravity
sucking him down to the earth have you
ever smoked dmt no it's like a
dimethyltryptamine your body produces it
it's in your
in your in your body and it kind of is
responsible for the dream state that we
experience as humans
it's chemical really interesting amazing
stuff yeah the civic nationalist says in
britain we already tried the market
approach
open borders with legal routes our
culture is eroded
limited immigration is better if you
want your culture to survive
but you but your yanks you wouldn't
understand
wigs all right
ender says you said that talented people
create investment which creates work
followed up by saying
work is not finite but the talented
people are finite after
after all how many talented people do
you know in your life compared to
untalented people
i think people can develop their talents
yeah and in a society where jobs are
most rapidly being destroyed that's
where talents are
varied talents are most most developed
there's just no getting around it
back before job destruction you just had
to be a farmer no matter what now in my
case i would have been pretty pathetic
and probably would have committed
suicide early
so thank goodness for the robots that
destroy the work of the past
all right we got uh we got some spicy
criticism you ready for what
says this guy is a neo-feudalist sitting
in his ivory tower telling the serfs to
eat cake while importing their
replacements for half the cost
he doesn't live in reality literal
lolbertarian
well what can i say
it's it's always been the case that uh
the the past
replaces the future and thank goodness
that parts of the world are doing the
work that we
that we used to do because the work we
used to do is something that this person
is criticizing me
probably couldn't handle this person is
as actually
is watching tv from a computer and
tapping out messages on a computer
will you throw all that away because
other than the tractor and fertilizer
the computer is easily
the biggest displacer of humans in
history and so it's probably a good idea
for you to give up that technology if
you really feel that way
all right let's see suga
sugaiana ram says legal immigration
needs to be fixed as well
it's a way for a company to import cheap
labor a lot of legal workers are stuck
on visas and companies take advantage of
their situation
government doesn't want to fix there was
one instance where
i saw this documentary companies would
advertise
to illegal immigrants two people in
other countries to illegally immigrate
to work for them
have them work for a guaranteed wage
standard wage but then before paying
them they would call ice or ins and have
them all
deported and they would pay nothing that
absolutely meant
nobody was getting paid not the worker
and not but i suppose that's you know
people break the law break the law
that's super
shady i guess it wasn't illegal though
no it should be profiting off of someone
else for breaking the law is
blackmail i think um and it should be
illegal
i think that qualifies as evil but
but let's never forget that the most
expensive labor in the world is cheap
labor
think about it henry ford
there's this urban myth that henry ford
raised wages to five dollars a day to
get
his employees to buy cars oh please you
think that would sustain the company
he did it because his turnover annually
was 370 percent he kept
losing workers because he wasn't paying
them enough
look in the united states where does the
most investment go oh yes san francisco
boston new york
to where the labor is most expensive
it's expensive to have cheap labor
because they quit
they don't take the job seriously it's
not
easy no one no business no one building
a business is actively looking for cheap
labor there's just certain work
jobs that don't don't rate a lot of pay
but there's a big difference
all right let's see we got here david
palmer says undocumented immigrant slave
wage labor is the backbone of the
californian economy
of course it is a sanctuary state
not true no
i i would say that california's economy
economy's backbone is not
its farming economy not its farming
economy i thought the farming was
a massive massive portion i mean like a
third at least right
no i'd if it is i'm very surprised that
california's economy is one of the most
advanced in the world as we discussed
california used to be a manufacturing
economy in the 1920s and 30s
it no longer is thank goodness it isn't
it would be a poor country it'd be a
poor state if it were
a third oh wow california provides a
third of the country's vegetables
wow yeah probably but i don't that
doesn't make it a the third largest
yeah so i just think it's the first
thing that pops up i don't know
uh let's see wow well i will have to
look that up later i guess
yeah all right let's see we got nick
tilly says
chat has many thumbs downs and dislikes
they are an example of what's wrong with
the world they reject sound logic and
truth love this podcast and guest
keep up the good work yeah i'll tell you
what one of the biggest problems is
that most people i you know are they
like the show they'll give us a thumbs
up
not everybody we're going to have on the
show is going to have the same opinion
you know so we're going to have people
we disagree with and have debates and
argue arguments with
but crowder was pointing this out too
stephen crowder was mentioning that yeah
so they'll do a segment about something
someone is
you know public figure is saying and
then people will give
crowder a thumbs down because people
don't like the opinion from
other people on the show or the segments
so it's like yeah you're hurting crowder
or you're hurting us
because you don't like the opinions of a
particular individual
honestly i think there's a lot of people
who do that because they want to make
sure the conversation can only go in one
direction
because if the weaker weaker-minded
people would say oh no the audience is
mad at us because we had a guest who has
a bad opinion i'm going to be like i'll
book them again
you know yeah yeah i don't i don't look
i'm not the smartest person in the world
people disagree with me and i disagree
with people
executed galileo because he kept saying
that uh
what is it the earth revolves around the
sun and so they
killed him like that's how much they
hated that idea that's crazy you can't
do that with new ideas
tolerance all right the quove says the
super com
that supercomputer is so cheap because
it's made by slaves in china please find
me a phone
made fully in western countries and
compare a cost
uh it's funny that he says that slaves
make it in china because
all i know is american businesses are
all over china and they say that it's
the second
it's the second largest market for nike
for mcdonald's there are 4 100 starbucks
in china on the way to 7
000. gm sells more cars in china than it
does in north america
if it were slaves working there how
could they afford all these expensive
american products
there's this myth about slave labor in
china oh please that's just i mean
the people in the foxconn labs were
walking off the building to their
suicide
uh there are certain they're always
going to be unhappy people in bad work
situations but to pretend that it's
slave labor in china
presumes that american companies are
just there why were they i spoke they
were slaves in the soviet union where
were all the american companies in the
former soviet union i'm just curious
plus you need to define slave like
slaves made nothing
but these people are making wages
they're just making and they're making
more and more the reality is people
they wouldn't like 400 bucks a month uh
they're probably some
there's no there are low-wage workers in
the u.s let's agree that they're
low-wage workers in china but as
evidenced by the fact that so many u.s
businesses are so eager to be there and
and
businesses from around the world that
are not there because the people are all
exploited because
what would the market be but yes there
are low-wage workers in china just as
there are in every other country
or maybe slaves made something i don't
know if that's a definitive statement
yeah slavery itself is a tragic system
but
let's let's not this is not traditional
slavery
all right we got sideways he says should
i buy stock in graphene tech early on
i would just like to point out i uh i
bought some some stock in a graphene
company
and uh it it went up it improved perhaps
we will
start a graphene company and then i
would encourage you to invest in that to
help us
grow it but that's a whole other yeah
i'm not a financial analyst so i can't
give you
definitive you know but graphene will be
becoming more popular as the years go on
the great companies of the future if we
knew about them we'd already own them
which means we don't own them go back we
don't know the great companies of the
future
everybody wants to go back in time and
buy bitcoin yeah yep yeah it's so easy
to look at in
in the rearview mirror but uh amazon is
one of the most valuable companies in
the world
its stock imploded more than 20 so many
times over the last 20 years
i'll tell you what's funny is uh it's a
rough ride if you're a shareholder 10
years ago i met a guy who was bragging
about how much money he made of his
apple stock
if i had just listened to him and said
i'll buy some apple stock
yep i'd make a ton of money but i was
like i don't know i missed that train
huh no
no well think about tesla when did it go
public
think how many years you owned a stock
that went nowhere
and then all of a sudden markets
discovered the potential
it's a tough business but but but that's
again i think that speaks why it's hard
for the state to control this
uh most investors don't presume to know
wall street doesn't presume to know what
the bet the companies the future are
it's very hard
uh to present pretend that that the
state could knows uh
all right cassius cam says millennials
don't have jobs because they're soft
i work at a lumber mill 20 an hour entry
level we can't find young people to to
hire
they're soft wow i agree yeah i i don't
like these these
i i tell you man i i made the mistake
early on in my career of seeking out
college graduates
thinking like you know find somebody's
got a degree my friend
said the same thing and it was a mistake
these kids they they graduate college
have never had a real job
are soft and incapable they've spent
their whole lives being told what to do
you need to find somebody who can roll
up their sleeves and solve a problem
not everybody's not absolute but that's
what i learned
yeah um do you remember that movie uh
uh slacker about austin texas in the
early 90s
see when i got out of college they said
that my generation x was going to be
a failure that we were going to live in
our parents basements that we would
never earn any money so they made movies
about a slacker singles
reality bites there are books about it
every
young generation in america's history
has been viewed as soft there is a
famous businessman who said that
americans
youth were so lazy that don't even
bother communism on them they'd be too
lazy to produce for others
who wrote this albert hubbard he wrote
it in 1899 he said the grandparents the
greatest generation
were too lazy and entitled and spoiled
we're always spoiled in the united
states why
because we've been defined by constant
progress the way the young people live
is so much better than their parents
live
guaranteed these young people who are
soft today
give them 20 to 30 years they'll be
saying these kids coming out of college
are so
soft i can't be bothered with them you
guys know uh the far side comics gary
larson yeah
there's one i love it it is a couple of
parents
sitting watching their son play nintendo
and they're
imagining job description wanted
super mario expert defeat bowser 10 an
hour wanted super mario pro
and it was joking about how these kids
playing video games were not going to
get jobs in the future
and now esports is a massive industry
one of the biggest tournament prize pool
for any sport was in video games
you got people who are some of the
richest people on the planet playing
video games on the internet
oh yeah and they were made fun of what
people need to realize is that value
exchange can be literally anything
yep so when right now look at the
stupidest thing in the world some kids
are doing
there's going to be a community that
values whatever that is maybe there's
kids and they
they walk around playing patty cake all
day and you're like oh these kids in
their patty cake trend
and then maybe in the future there's
going to be a group of people that large
enough to where they value paddy kick
tournaments
and these people can make money from it
i'm not saying it's that's that will be
playing petty cake but who knows
but but you're absolutely right the
definition of an entrepreneur is someone
who
believes something deeply that most
everyone rejects
and so and this has not me talk my i
wrote a book about this called the end
of work that the future of work in the
us is going to be so amazing
and video games was one of them if you
had told someone when i was growing up
think about when you got into video
games in the early 1980s yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna do this for a job in the
future they would have thought you had a
substance abuse problem
if you had said i'm going to be a video
game coach which there now are and they
make a lot of money
they would have committed you there's a
pro
professor entrepreneur i know his son 10
years ago said hey dad why don't i start
taping myself playing video games
people would love to see it have you
lost your mind well so of course there's
huge money in that now
the work the definition of work in a
free society
changes all the time and in ways that is
is fascinating
so is it any wonder that kids are soft
what they get to do what their future of
work is going to be so
different from the past that a work is a
scientific term
that just defines energy production
measured in jewels
and so what is work i mean we're working
right now we're producing work
can you believe how lucky we are at what
we get to do
because i guarantee your ancestors
weren't getting to do something
so fun that paid the bills and had
lights around them
and getting to project these ideas to so
many people
it is amazing work is an historical
concept and
thank goodness in free rich countries
it's constantly changing
that is progress where the work of the
past is being destroyed it's not a
negative and it's not ivory tower
now i'll shout out to our lumber mill
friend and just say
there are some people who are faced with
the choice 20 plus
hour 20 an hour to start in a lumber
mill or
65 000 a year to go work for a rage bait
blog in new york and write about brad
pitt's junk
which one's the easier job which one do
you think they're gonna choose to do
i'm not a fan of that i think people
need to learn how to do trades and go
work in a lumber mill and i don't value
people writing about brad pitt's junk
but the attention economy took over
and keep in mind at the lumber mill the
machines are doing a lot of the work
so that word work is very
amorphous we need to make exo suits
you're right ian yeah we do
this dude in the lumber mill shouldn't
have to they shouldn't hire somebody
they should build massive
mechs that can just pick up a giant tree
and just go
wing and just like yeah it wouldn't
really be effective convincing tim to do
a show where we go try on exo suits
travel around the world and try on like
crazy technologies yeah
all right so if you have access let me
know philip summit says hey guys it's my
birthday tomorrow
i know you guys like to talk about god a
lot have you considered having dr tim
mackey from the bible project on he's an
interesting bible scholar and also
happens to be a skateboarder oh that
sounds pretty cool
it might be fun i would like to if we
didn't like that though i'd like i'd
like to get some kind of
um i'd like to have
not just a bible expert but also maybe
like a dmt expert as well
where we could have this intersection
between faith religion but also
psychedelics experience
and maybe find some like interesting
points that could be made
in common you know what i mean yeah
happy birthday by the way tomorrow
absolutely we got too many super chats
man
thank you guys sonny james says uh dude
if i hear petrol oil came from dinosaur
blood one more time
dude a raccoon died in my front yard and
had a 20-foot oil ring
could have ran an 18-wheeler off one
raccoon literally the dumbest thing i've
ever heard with my own two months
wow great super chat
wow uh i was listening to this podcast
one of the it's one of the top podcasts
and they were like
you know fossil fuels can't last forever
because there's no more dinosaurs and
the other guy's like yeah like the
dinosaurs are gone it's like
oh jeez there's no more fossils man
first of all
it was not made of dinosaurs it is just
highly compressed organic matter i
believe it's mostly algae right i could
be wrong oh
probably yeah it was it was it was
compressed algae and things like that
just decaying organic matter more
importantly we already
synthesized petroleum by creating we
made algae
and then we we like superheated and
compressed it and turned it into a
hydrocarbon fuel
so yes it can be made if we want to do
it honestly your body is
secreting oil right now i wonder if we
can utilize that someday maybe
let's see drew burchett says hey tim you
got called out by steve at pt news as an
idiot for your tweet
on the pro act your plan is working uh
the tweet the tweet i put out about the
the it's the protect the right to
organize
act you're familiar with this vaguely
it's it's
the argument is that from many many
people including on the left is that it
would eliminate freelancing
because it's it's similar to
california's ab5
which says you know uber and these
companies are exploiting labor and so
it empowers unions and so i tweeted we
must help the democrats pass the pro
act because it will help uh union you
know unions and labor rights it will
also destroy
rage bait woke websites because
they run off freelance labor the the the
point of the tweet essentially is
it's true it will destroy those
companies like it did in california but
uh
what who's this guy what's pt news is he
right or left-wing because i can imagine
they're both mad at me and that's kind
of the point i don't know
i'm gonna fight for union labor and
destroy leftist rage bait both sides get
mad
thank you i love it it took me only like
a week to get called left-wing by
right-wing media and right-wing by
left-wing media
fantastic let's see
skeleton king says i live close to
aliquippa the downtown area is so bad
right now the local leaders need to step
up
bummer colin burke says tim i've got a
new album
louder actions and two years clean i
truly believe in my music any advice for
promo in the digital climate
clear.bandcamp.com by the way love one
man music operation colin burke
hey congratulations dude sounds good do
you have advice for him promoting
i don't know because i'm trying to
promote my song i don't even know what
we're doing with it
that's asking a lot promoting you can
buy facebook ads
like target them to people to like that
kind of music i feel like there's so
much money
i just feel like it's got to be organic
like you know making youtube videos
consistently every day yeah but that's a
lot of work
we we put out uh i put out my song will
of the people on november
2nd just before the election and it's
got just about 900 000 views
all organic no ads nothing is just
people listening some people sharing it
and uh we're we're thinking about
something we can do to promote it but i
kind of feel like we should
finish the album first which who knows
who knows how long that'll take because
i work too much as it is think how
amazing that is though because if you
did you ever read that
keith richards uh biography so he said
if you got studio time
in the 60s you took it it was so
difficult so expensive to get
yet here's tim producing an album and
has reached 900 000 people again the
ways in which
in the cheap ways thanks to technology
that you can get things out
as we could hope really
wow yeah i mean uh we we well
we made a video for it we did a short
film so that was the bulk of the cost
animation and stuff but you are right if
you have like uh a couple some computer
programs a microphone
and you're an internet access you can
basically produce
if you know what you're doing and you
have logic you know or some
you can basically my friend dave days
shout out dave one of the og youtube
million subscribers when he was 18. he's
produced a lot of great music just from
his room
all right we got patrick in chicago says
i grew up in flint factories left
because politics and unions
talent left when jobs left nothing flint
made is
unneeded or obsolete just made by cheap
foreign labor and shipping bat and
shipped back
svc industry jobs aren't good paying
jobs
service industry jobs
austin unra says ian the population of
the world is aging
and we are on course for a population
crash in the next 30 to 40 years
and there is not the population to
replace it
hmm that's crazy yeah you talked about
it would you think so
oh think about that the people being
born today are going to be exponentially
more productive than the people born in
the past
the discovery of coal was thought to be
the equivalent of
someone suddenly having 20 personal
assistants helping him or her doing work
so what does the internet do what does
the computer do once again you guys are
producing a tv show from here with
exponentially less
human labor the product productive
capacity of humans
today is so amazing relative of the past
is it any wonder that we're producing
less kids
when we used to produce kids because we
needed extra hands on the farm
let's also point out that what's the
country that is
has the lowest birth rate and highest
suicide rate
south korea oh is it struggling right
now
no it's booming this notion about a
population crash
it's basically global warming for the
from for the right
it's the the there's so many people on
the right looking for some reason the
world's going to end and this is one of
them
yeah actually after the plague in in
europe the economy flourished
you had this high level of technology
and lots of people dead so all of a
sudden the economy was just
taken off like crazy with all this work
that had to be done and all this
opportunity to do it
it's kind of nightmarish you know that's
what caused it but
well and in fairness think about the
let's just look at the holocaust in
europe
there's this there's this view that
today in the economics profession that
the
world war ii ended the great depression
i can't think of
something more horrifyingly obtuse
implicit there is that you can grow your
economy
by killing your best customers and also
sending your best people your best and
brightest out to war where they can be
destroyed that you can grow your economy
by destroying wealth
imagine where europe would be today if
people like hitler hadn't destroyed so
many so much human capital imagine where
russia would be today if they hadn't
gotten into such
needless wars and so humans are always
the drivers of
of progress but to pretend that that
birth rates are the drivers of progress
presumes that botswana has a much bigger
economy than south korea
and so no all right stupidly awesome
gaming says
second time's the charm hope this makes
it please shout out my friend
cameron zwick for making me a dedicated
listener for four years
you inspired me to do more streaming in
youtube thank you so much much
love appreciate it cool very nice joshua
albritton says great golem impression
yesterday
loved hearing you and ian talk tolkien
if interested
i translated the entirety of the hobbit
into elvish won't let me post the link
so shoot me a message if you want a free
copy
fyi tim is frodo and i am sam
he has the chat he's carrying the ring
right now you guys it's the darkness of
the political the world he's taking on
his shoulders we need to help him
destroy the ring definitely not frodo
not by choice
i just see you carrying the burden bro
i'm not i'm not sitting in that
fellowship round table going like i will
carry it
now i'm sitting there going like don't
look at me you're the only one that can
i'm not doing it i don't know why
gandalf gave fro to the ring why was he
chosen
no one does because his hobbits are are
less corruptable
they were simple focus wanted to drink
and be married and they were liberated
the hobbits weren't a war like people
right well because bilbo was the one who
found it
and so frodo was the one who had it and
it just fell upon him but i mean you
know samwise helped come on
dude don't come on yeah what are you
doing sam's the man
they destroyed it together that's right
yeah i love sam and frodo almost didn't
do it
because the cop no no your russia was
corrupted and then gollum
no one can carry that burden alone yeah
it's hard yeah man
what what what what what great
storytelling
again we just used the one ring from the
lord of rings analogy for political
power
mm-hmm i think it's a good i think that
was the point actually so
i fell asleep in the first one i just i
can't i know
sacrilegious shun the non-believer out
of the students from ours
yeah yes
books are great all right garen says
john the we do it two is fallacious
give me an example right now not 100
years ago china enslaves three million
uyghurs
forcibly aborts sterilizes steals
children murders
and sells their organs china is world
war ii germans
again i'm not going to defend certain
things that go on in china but
and and i love the united states but
have you checked out the indian health
service right now
guess where they send the doctors who
can't work anywhere else and
who've been d d licensed for fraud they
usually send them to indian hospitals
just as one example should we indict the
united states for the the mistakes made
when it was initially a free country i
think not
it doesn't defend what happened for one
second slavery was a tragedy
the treatment of the indians was a
tragedy i do not like what government
does and so let's never forget
government is doing this i am for
limited government
governments that are have too much power
constantly make mistakes do we want to
talk about the millions of americans
presently incarcerated
because they'll have a different way of
getting high than
the politicians would like or they meet
the needs of those who have a different
way of getting high
uh the list goes on and on i don't trust
government you shouldn't either
if i was gonna run for office there was
only there there only be
one thing i would campaign on if i was
gonna run for president one thing and
i'm old enough to run for president now
apparently
and it would be that the only thing i'll
do for you okay i was i'm gonna go in
and i am going to get a gigantic stack
of all of the
incarcerated federal inmates on
non-violent judge
drug charges we're going to go through
them and we're going to remove people
who
who pleaded down from violent charges
because someone committed a violent
crime no no
i'm sorry you're you you get you go to
prison but for everybody who got
arrested because they were doing a
little bit of drugs here and there
i'm just going to start rubber stamping
pardons that's it rubber stamping those
pardons i'll be in office for one day i
will resign
i'll get a vice president who has a plan
or something and i'll just be like you
vote for me
i'm going to go in and i'm going to
commute the sentences of all of these
people pardon every single one of them
then i'm going to pass a bunch of
executive orders saying stop enforcing
these particular laws and then they'll
sue me and do whatever they want and
i'll be like whatever i don't care
that's my purpose i'm leaving
i don't want to do anything else i don't
want to be in charge of anybody i don't
want to deal with war
all i want to do is finally get someone
to go in and be like this dude was was
was was rocking the ganja by himself
and now he's in prison none of that amen
i want to get granules on all these
executive orders you want to sign
you want to what tell me about these
executive orders you want to sign
maybe not right now oh like like stop
having the feds go after people who are
minding their own business and enjoying
you know
partaking in some contraband substance
prohibition doesn't work
i'm not a fan of it if somebody wants to
go into like their their back room with
dark lights
and you know blast off to meet the elves
why is it anybody's business
why why do you go to prison for that
that's dumb i don't know
yeah yeah exactly people want to eat
mushrooms well some places have
legalized
or decriminalized mushrooms i think it's
because they're afraid free thinkers
will overthrow the government so they're
trying to subvert the free thinking i
think
there's a dude right now and he's got
some love beads
in front of his door he's got black
lights and posters with glowing
mushrooms and all he wants to do is sit
there and his
he got off work he worked you know he's
got he's got tough stressful job
maybe you know maybe he works in the
sewer maybe he's wearing waders in these
suits and he's going down and wading
through sewers to pull rat kings out of
pipes
to clear the clogs and all he wants to
do when he gets home is take a little
dmt and blast off to meet the elves
neurogenesis now you go to prison for
that yeah he's not hurting anybody
no well i suppose if you want him to be
of sound mind there's certain
limitations you know don't be high while
you're in the sewer because you know you
can get hurt or whatever
but look there are certain substances
that i think
if somebody chooses to do it i it's it's
weird to me that the government puts
people in prison for non-violent
offenses with no victim
the victim is the person who chose to do
it that's so dumb selling it to kids
okay that i get you know don't do that
kind of stuff
all right let's see john baloo says tim
moved to texas
very business friendly and there's a ton
of us tv and film workers here ready to
go
i will say this about texas texas is
awesome
it's like probably my favorite state you
know if i was gonna have to pick a state
because
it's texas you know what i mean i mean
you got guns i love texas yeah you go to
the store you buy a bottle of whiskey
they
by law have to give you you know a smith
and wesson 500
that's a family guy joke um the problem
is
a lot of people are going to texas right
now and it feels just like they're
following the crowd
you know so i'm looking for something
new i don't want to i don't want to do
what everyone else does i want to find
something new and build something new
and uh yeah we're out in the middle of
nowhere so we're not in
well well you mentioned where we were
for those most people probably know
about did
i cross the line in saying that no
because
there was an article that came out that
like they were trying to smear me
i don't want to talk too much about it
but they they went above and beyond to
make sure everybody knew exactly where
we were and it's like a mainstream
news outlet trying to just uh get us
hurt i suppose
but uh anybody who wanted to google it
knows we're in maryland so
but uh it is what it is all right let's
grab some more super chats here we'll do
a little bit more we're going a little
bit over but
we had a ton of super chats oh yeah
thank you guys yes it's really good
archangel says ian said graphene
everyone drink
federal reserve graphene blockchain
and lord of the rings i have more things
to say
yeah we got that too we need to start
setting we
need we need to set up a a uh like a dnd
show a dnd
podcast i guess i'm so ready i have the
the beginning of the campaign ready to
go we just i want you guys to make your
own characters
yeah you know you know about dungeons
and dragons oh yeah
you ever play it no never i've only ever
done that one time at the theater
with uh with with you guys but it's i i
i think some people probably take it
really seriously i'd imagine where
they're actually like taking the numbers
down
for us it was kind of like we're sitting
around eating pizza and drinking and
cracking jokes about stupid
guess what character you guys think tim
made for his dnd campaign and i'll tell
you at the end of the show so type it in
chat
oh yeah yeah yeah here's your chance to
super chat what you think my dnd
character is
and uh i'm willing to bet people are
going to get it oh yes
i think people are going to know i'll
tell you in a minute all right yeah so
we'll read some more super chats and
then we'll see what you guys say
uh artemis fowl says what's this guy's
social credit score
uh seven seven out of five
out of what though i don't know seven
could be good yeah yeah ten could be
good
or a thousand twenty five hundred twenty
five hundred
eight hundred like actual credit all
right
uh nosferatu says chat's stuck on ccp
shill sad now there's these amount of
people who
aren't fans yes i think i think most
people are willing to recognize that
everybody agrees with them though
it's always hard because i want you know
i i'm not going to shy away from the
criticism super chats the same time
but i don't want to make it seem like
everyone's angry when some people are
angry you know what i mean
that's a big um topic to talk about a
corrupt government and then the
economics underneath
this this is a good super jet so my god
this is awesome lol says
fight me five year bet john so uh
five years i guess if you're wrong you
gotta you gotta eat a bobcat
okay okay got five years i better be
right then
all right tyler pruitt says china banned
animal crossing because people were
protesting and organizing there come on
man
come on man come on man come on china's
abandoned animal crossing yeah people i
guess reporting free hong kong and
animal crossing
so they got rid of the game
too late
trent lomolino says john is a ccp
operative
prove me wrong if only i was an
operative that would presume they were
paying me something hey
no you know look uh it's interesting how
there are
pro pro like america first libertarians
and then
more open trade open
how is the right word for that economic
trade international trade libertarians
where they're like i don't think i've
met a
a a big libertarian that's outright said
open the borders entirely no
restrictions
i think it's mostly similar to what
you're saying like legalize it have them
come in through a normal process to make
it a lot easier
you know is that is that common yeah i
mean probably in my perfect world
yeah i look borders are open in the
united states right now it's not like
everyone's
flowing out of west virginia into
virginia i mean think about it you know
well
actually well west virginia offered to
actually annex several parts of virginia
because of their laws
people are flooding out of michigan like
crazy
yeah they are but there's michigan still
got a population
you know texas has always bragged that
they take people from california at a
high rate every day
you know texas used to be mexico so
wait wait wait so we like them if they
if they're in in
texas but we don't like if they come
from mexico in my
perfect idealistic world i i would
market forces applied everything and
human capital they want to come to the
united states
obviously they're not going to haiti
haiti doesn't have an immigration
problem does it
and so i would like to legalize it but i
think it's worth compromising on this
one
if is just say okay just announce
yourself
works legal citizenship is probably more
distant object most of them don't want
it in the first place they just want to
work here
it's a market signal if we crash the
economy they won't be coming here
all right madison mcafee says tim you
should invite a rational and logical
female millennial
obtaining a bs in maths with
concentration in stats
who goes against your stigmas i mean me
invite me also en t plus two equals four
base number systems has nothing to do
with the argument
oh snap
[Laughter]
oh man have that person on uh madison
send an email to what's been the ufo
uh yeah yeah we'll figure some out yeah
yeah
everyone wants to be on the show though
so i'm not trying to you know i was kind
of being facetious because i don't know
who you are but
i like your comment do you like to bet
them a little bit
rocky truman says are you wearing off
last night you were swatting bugs not so
much tonight okay
there's no food in the studio the
closest thing we have to it is there's a
bowl of fruit snacks that no one really
ever takes barbecuing downstairs though
i thought
probably yeah probably yeah so food's
downstairs way far away okay so ian is
his coffee
uh-huh but we come up we come up and the
studio table is covered in ants so i
guess what happens is it got warm
and they started looking for just
yesterday they were over here
it is possible someone put like a
something in the trash can like a
oh they were nowhere near the trash
empty bottle sweet sugar
they were on the they were on the table
not doing anything they were just
randomly running around
so there's no line of them no no no they
were probably just looking for stuff and
yes tim was swatting ants all night yeah
i was going live
kicking them up and saying six million
tickets right nice
i don't think there's any i haven't seen
anything i've seen it i have not been
attacked by even
good good they're very friendly it's a
great first impression for
jim all right the red hydra says have
you considered jacksonville florida for
a new home base we got plenty of
property great beaches and international
airport kona skate park no state tax and
so much more
plus it's florida we're back in business
it is beautiful jacksonville i love it
there you're good
i really like it jacksonville is is
is what that's closer to the panhandle
right it's up north it's like you're in
georgia but you're in florida
so you get the the the right wingness if
you prefer that of georgia but you get
florida taxes
it's just it's just it's just too hot
too
much florida hot as h here in the summer
time that's true
in washington washington dc is just
swamp absolutely yeah swamp wasn't it
literally a swamp
yes i think so i think that's the point
right and so yeah right right right
all right arbiter media says another ian
special move could be a
could be oh wait could be a backhand
releasing the code leaving opponents
dazed and dumbfounded
by so much knowledge but power only him
and tim can harness
i'll be like yeah and then you'll see
like the green letters behind me like
the major letters and then it's like
ian's free the code ability is where he
fires he he connects the graphene wires
from his fingertips to the person and it
disables their technology
and like like whatever their special
moves are you'll see code burst from
their attack and their tech shuts off
all right and then it stuns their
specials for like five or ten seconds
it's gonna be a cybernetic fighting game
yeah
well some people have magic powers you
know jordan peterson
his super move will be that his his he
he he looks down and
energy starts like coming off of his
body and then he punches the ground and
then all of a sudden a gigantic lobster
erupts yeah that comment and then he
rides it and then it slams into you
lobster summon that yeah it's great and
joe rogan would literally just be normal
mma moves yep yeah
yeah all normal i feel like the wrestler
like zhang jieff
i want to see if people what their
guesses were to uh
what they what they thought i would be
and uh so
let's let's see what we got here what
kind of dnd character you think tim
yeah so let's see some super chats of
what people thought what kind of weapon
or weapons was he using what was his
class all right
so this is wrong jack bensavanga says i
don't know much about dnd but i'm
assuming tim was a bard of some sort
and close well i'll say why i said that
was close afterwards
ian should watch knights of i don't know
what that is
uh let's see another person said tim is
a bard for sure absolutely incorrect
interesting you would like that class
though bard no i wouldn't
absolutely not we went over this well
they're similar
okay you want me to tell no no
yes all right let's see small
insects live in banana peels look it up
thank yous oh my god this is awesome lol
that was a very very important super
chat no bananas up here guys
none all right i guess i guess there's
not many people who have any other guys
well the answer is
we gotta make sure gotta make sure i
wanna be fair to the people who super
chatted
with they're with their guests yeah i
don't see it no i think that's it i
think
most people are just complaining about
china tim was quarter elf
rogue quarter alpha i mean it's a it was
a half elf
for the rules but you have your quarter
i was like can i be a quarter elf
yeah you're like same bonuses but you're
basically a half but he was a
charismatic
diplomat kind of like the bard the bard
relies heavily on charisma and has some
rogue abilities
like this i was a rogue with high
charisma yep
huh yeah and it was it was funny i
convinced the barmaid to
to give everyone goat's milk which
turned out to be spoiled
and then i spoiled goat's milk is just
chev and everyone enjoyed it they
celebrated having goats cheese i
remember that
basically you know we're not the kind of
people that play d and d like all
serious like i am a wizard and i will
blast you with magic it's more like all
right so my guy you know he punches a
dude in the balls and then steals his
beer and then like we're all drinking
three guys stand up around them roll
initiative
that's what you say when confidence
emerges yeah it was just fun silly
jokes that's why it would be a great
like podcast show because it's basically
just people hanging out
cracking jokes and it's just comedy
silliness and
you know like i grabbed the chicken from
outside and i throw it at the guy and
the chicken scratches his face and other
silly nonsense all right everybody
thanks so much for hanging out with us
on
friday night i know most of you could be
at the bar and get your game on but
instead you come here to listen to us
talk about very important things so
thanks so much appreciate it leave us a
good like smash that like button because
when you like when you comment you're
telling youtube that you really like the
show and youtube takes that into
consideration
also go over to timcast.com become a
member because
let me tell you something somebody uh
made a video where they were like tim
poole's got to see this
and then they're they're a bmx writer
and i've been talking about how we want
to get
more than just skateboarding going on
here so you guys ride scooters if you're
aggressive inline if you're bmx if
you're skateboarders
we want to make videos and there's some
stuff we have to go through in terms of
like legal process but uh
so uh somebody hit us up they want to
film a video and they look like they're
pretty good at bmx so we're gonna film
that
and uh i i am very confident probably
like sunday night it'll be up on the
blog section of the website so that'll
be free for everybody
whether you're a member or not and
because this is just more i don't know
it might be like a 10 minute vlog video
of skateboarding and bmx and inline or
whatever we end up doing
and then maybe we'll like show the
chickens a little bit but we're actually
going to film this because we actually
do have someone planning on coming out
so check that out we're going to be
ramping things up we are planning the
vlog now that things are getting nicer
a whole lot of work's got to get done we
are going to be bringing back friday
night music
we are going to be setting up live shows
in our venue space so we'll actually get
bands and comedians and actually have
these events and that means also members
will be invited to come because we need
an audience for these events so
that's going to be a lot of work a lot
of people that we have to hire
and uh things are expanding really
really quickly so to everybody who tuned
in
thanks so much for hanging out you can
check out the show monday to friday live
at 8pm
you can follow me on all social media
platforms at timcast
and my other youtube my other youtube
channels are youtube.com timcast
youtube.comcastnews
leave us a good review if you're
listening on itunes and again subscribe
we're going to break a million subs by
next week i hope
that'll be awesome and uh you want to
shout anything out i know you got a book
john
oh well thank you so much what a
pleasure it was to be here yes this is
my new book
uh all everyone should buy several
copies or something like that but thank
you so much for engaging me when
great conversation i learned yeah i
thought it was fantastic
oh yeah your twitter what is your
twitter oh at john tammany
so it very original again the name john
tammany
when politicians panic when politicians
panicked as the book it's on
all the major platforms uh to be uh
this was really enjoyable man thanks for
coming thank you thank you i kind of
feel like we barely kind of scratched
the surface on
some issues about the economy but it was
really really great to hear
a lot about from what your perspective
on this stuff is well thank you very
much i learned so much
for coming you guys can follow me in
crossland.net and get my socials from
there we are building the fetaverse out
which is a decentralized internet
service where we're going to allow
people to
tim wants to add some well it exists
already we're building it out
we we want to we want to kind of add to
this protocol in a very positive way to
expand free speech and free thought
using like the matrix and we're going to
make
we're attempting to build a subscription
model service that
basically we cut out the middleman like
there's not going to be a patreon or
anything like that this
this technology will function as that
service for you so you'll be able to
describe
subscribe to different websites around
the internet and and
handle payments and process that way so
if you want to get involved with that if
you're a developer
and you'd like to help please contact me
on twitter with a direct message you can
also message me on minds
and i'll set you up with our chat room
or fetiverse chatroom
the idea basically is if you want to
create a page that's
like a subscription service patreon we
would
we would give you this open source
package that you could just install on a
server
you know let's say you buy server space
from some company you have a domain name
you click this button boom it expands it
runs on the server and now you've got
your own
version of like timcast.com or something
where you can upload content for members
only
you can take membership subscriptions so
then all of these independent
commentators creators influencers don't
need to give 10 percent some company for
no reason
there'll be an open source version the
open source team will build upon it
because they want to build upon it i
mean we use open source software across
the board for a lot of what we do
and a lot of people need to realize this
too a lot of servers run on linux
because it's free it's cheap it's
effective open source is amazing
and i really want to uh i want to get
rid of these middlemen
who can ban you can destroy your careers
and destroy your lives
the best part is that what we want to do
with the fetiverse this is this is a
decentralized network for social media
the idea would be on your website
there's a networking discover section
which shows you all these other websites
that use the same service so it creates
a decentralized network of people just
using a similar code
effectively a totally decentralized
social media subscription influencer
platform no one can ban you from
except your own business partner so
that's the plan man but ian's basically
running it so
get involved hit you up on twitter hit
me up on twitter man right now
this we also got sour patches i'm
technically here pushing buttons in the
corner
um i am sarah patchell is on twitter and
minds and gab instagram i am sour patch
lids on a few platforms so just follow
me wherever
thanks for hanging out everybody check
out timcast.com become a member and we
will see you all next time bye guys
you